All right.
What is up, y'all? As always, welcome to
another live stream. Still getting used
to uh having three monitors here. So, if
I'm kind of looking around um kind of in
like a a spaceship, if you will, um of
monitors here. So, thanks for showing
up. Going to be a good show tonight. uh
hopefully beneficial to both Adventists,
never been Adventists, uh and everyone
in between. Um so, by viewer request,
tonight we're going to be reviewing and
responding to a message that Pastor
Steven Boore from Secrets Unsealed gave
at the 2023 few weeks ago, Michigan
conference camp meeting titled Deadly
Camouflage. Uh the irony of that title
will be clearer the further along that
we go. Uh I think there's a couple
reasons why this is going to be helpful
um for all the groups that I mentioned.
Um it's important to understand folks
that what unites 7th Day Adventists is
the great controversy worldview.
regardless of where an SDA is on the
spectrum, be it what they call
conservative traditional Adventists like
Steven Boore, um
all the way to the progressives, the
liberal strain that sees the
conservative strains as a outofdate
fundamentalist. Um despite this, the
glue that holds all of them together is
the day they go to church and their
shared great controversy worldview that
informs all of their theology, the way
they see the world, and so on. Uh, as
you're going to see tonight, um, there
are millions of Adventists out there
that will tell you they don't read Ellen
White. They only read the Bible. The
problem is the Bible is then being read
through the great controversy worldview,
which colors and shapes the scriptures
for them. So, let me get a couple things
set up here on my end as well.
But yeah, tonight I want to focus in on
that uh the worldview aspect of this um
and hopefully connect the dots for a
number of people including maybe some
Adventists uh whether it be tonight uh
10 years down the road, who knows? Um
but there's also going to be a mantra
for tonight and that is sir where is
that in the Bible? The Adventist church
like a broken record constantly asserts
they just believe the Bible. no creed
but the Bible. That's what's on their
own fundamental beliefs page.
Upholding the Protestant conviction of
solos scripter and then in quotes Bible
only. These 28 fundamental beliefs
describe how Seventh Day Adventists
interpret scripture for daily
application. Seventh Day Adventists
accept the Bible as their only creed and
hold certain fundamental beliefs to be
the teaching of the holy scriptures.
So keep that in mind and keep the great
controversy worldview in mind and how
they just defined solos scriptor by the
way um we're going to get to that in a
second um because spoiler alert that's
not what solos scriptor is um but just
remember too this question sir where is
that in the Bible but before getting
into the main video I want to listen to
a small clip from Steven Boore not the
main video that we're going to watch um
that's titled the Bible or tradition it
is a series that he taught um I don't
know about six years ago it was uploaded
to YouTube it it says and so we're going
to listen to a small clip here and I
want you to notice what he says after
what we just read as well on the
Adventist church's website
and so for the next 10 sessions we are
going to study what our source of
authority should be should it be the
Bible and the Bible only solar scriptor
or should it be tradition or a
combination of both?
All right. So, did you catch that?
He's going to defend the position in
that series if you watch it. What you
saw on the Adventist Church's website,
I've said it before and I'll keep saying
it. That is not what solos scriptor
means. That is the classic SDA term
borrowing that I always reference and I
harp on this a lot because I don't want
people associating the SDA view with the
classical Protestant view of solos
scriptura. They are not the same. So
don't lump us in with the way that
they're utilizing history and tradition
etc. What he stated and what's on the
Adventist church's website is what is
called biblicism. That is not solo
scriptor. The formal term would be nuda
scriptor denuding the scriptures from
history. It's this Bible and me under a
tree style idea that the Adventist
pioneers took um that all sorts of other
groups have taken and you see what it it
leads to. That's not what the Protestant
reformers were doing. If you read any of
the Protestant reformers, you're going
to read a lot of tradition because they
were not just saying these are my own
private interpretations that I'm coming
to. So believe me because we have a
prophet who puts a stamp of approval on
uh the interpretation that we arrive at.
I really wish Adventist leadership would
stop doing this and confusing people. It
is not no creed but the Bible which is
what they purport though you're about to
see that this is not true either. Um
solos scripture is a claim about
infallibility
that the only infallible God breathed
source of revelation that the church has
is scripture.
The phrase was said in the context of
infallible authorities,
not that the Bible's the only
theological source outright. Tradition
has a place. The Protestant argument
basically was that tradition and the
church are reformable. They're not
infallible.
It's not uh it's not a claim that only
the scriptures are the only thing that
you can look at for any sort of
theological insight or teaching or even
a level of authority.
Tradition does have a level of
authority. But nevertheless, Stephen
asked a question.
Should the Bible and the Bible only be
the source of authority? Should it be
tradition or a combination of both? in
this series, he's going to go on um to
assert that the Adventist position is
obviously, like I said, the first one.
Um so remember this, the question
tonight, sir, is sir, where's that in
the Bible? You claim it's Bible only and
the Bible only, not a combination of
tradition, not tradition, Bible only. So
at the start here, he's going to lay the
foundation for the talk, which is about
Satan's deceptions. So we're going to be
camping out in Genesis tonight. So, if
you want a Bible, get your Esword, your
physical Bible, whatever. Genesis 1, 2,
and 3. We'll go in a couple other
places, but Stephen is focusing in,
well, Genesis and um a lot of the spirit
of prophecy. Um, so he's going to lay
the framework for that. Just as a heads
up, we're going to play this at 1.25
speed to try and get through it a little
bit quicker. Um, he's still
understandable, but just know that it'll
sound a little bit different due to the
increased speed. So with that said,
let's get into this.
The book of revelation tells us
that Lucifer was successful in deceiving
onethird of the angels of heaven. So his
methods of deception must have been very
very strong. And then of course we know
that Satan tempted Eve, Eve, Adam. And
that's why we're here today.
The big question is, what methods did
Satan use to deceive our progenitors?
In the present study, we are going to
attempt to determine Satan's methods in
deception. I want to begin by reading a
statement that we find in manuscript
releases volume 10 and page 162.
This is how it reads.
If the angels were deceived by Lucifer's
ingenious methods of misrepresenting
God, if Adam and Eve were deceived by
his declaration that God was withholding
from them the higher education that
would make them as gods,
is there not danger that men today will
be deceived?
Please read the first chapter of
Patriarchs and Prophets and see if the
precious truths contained in this book
are not given by the Lord to protect his
people from from deceptions that are
urged upon them just now. There's
something special about studying the
first chapter of Patriarchs and
Prophets, which is a description of the
origin of evil in heaven. So, what we
want to do is go back to the Garden of
Eden and examine the methods that Satan
used to deceive Eve and then through Eve
to tempt and lead lead Adam into sin.
Okay, so right out of the gate, we have
blunders. Did you catch it?
Stephen tries saying Satan deceived Eve
and then Adam was tempted by Eve. But is
that what Ellen White said in that
quote? She does later in patriarchs and
prophets on page 56. She does say that
that Adam um or Eve was tempting Adam
and he's going to quote that. But what
did the quote he just read for
manuscript releases volume 10 say? Let's
look at this quote again after that.
Okay.
He starts right here. He says, "If the
angels were deceived by Lucifer's
ingenious methods of misrepresenting
God, if Adam and Eve were deceived,"
she says, "Both of them were deceived."
Let's look at a quote again,
another one. This is from her book,
Evangelism, on page 598. So leading up
to this quote, she's talking about
people who claim we don't have to keep
the ten commandments anymore have been
deceived by Satan um through his
craftiness. Then after that about Adam,
she says this,
"Satan, who is the father of lies,
deceived Adam in a similar way, telling
him that he need not obey God, that he
would not die if he transgressed the
law."
So what's the error, folks?
Well, first, Ellen White, Steven had a
split tone because in evangelism, she
says that Satan deceived Adam. Yet, in
Patriarchs and Prophets, you're going to
quote from page 55 here in a bit, where
she says, "Adam was the only one tempted
by Eve." While at the same time, you
just read a quote from manuscript
releases volume 10, where she said Adam
and Eve were both deceived by Satan's
declaration that God was withholding
something from them.
So, the first note that we have is that
this is why so many SDAs are confused,
folks.
They're being instructed by pastors that
are reading these this contradictory
mess and depending on which book for
Ellen White they're quoting from, you'll
hear contradictory statements. So
besides contradicting herself, let's
test this against scripture. What does
Paul tell Timothy when giving
instruction on roles within the church?
1 Timothy 2 12-14.
I do not permit a woman to teach or to
exercise authority over a man. Rather,
she's to remain quiet. For Adam was
formed first, then Eve, and Adam was not
deceived.
But the woman was deceived and became a
transgressor.
God's word saids Adam wasn't deceived.
Ellen says he was.
He wasn't deceived. Adam knew what he
was doing. Notice Paul mentions this in
a rather controversial paricopy of
scripture regarding male and female
roles within the church. Paul roots what
he said about women, pastors, and elders
essentially rooting it back in the
created order.
It's back in the creation of male and
female and the roles that God has given
them. With men, it's namely to lead,
protect, and provide. That's physically,
spiritually, emotionally, which is
precisely what Adam should have been
doing. He should have been protecting
his wife from the cunningness of the
serpent and his lies. Because Adam was
present when Eve was deceived. How do we
know this? Genesis 3:6 explicitly says
so and this is going to be vital to
remember for later in his message. So
what does Genesis 3:6 say?
So when the this is after she's been
deceived by by the devil. So when the
woman saw that the tree was good for
food, and that it was a delight to the
eyes, and that the tree was to be
desired to make one wise, she took of
its fruit and ate. And she also gave
some to her husband, who was with her,
and he ate.
So Adam should have been protecting Eve
as her husband. He didn't. He was
passive in his role as a man and husband
and didn't protect his wife from
theological deception. Men, this is a
reminder that if you are married, that
is your duty. You will give an
accounting to God for how you led in
this area. So, don't be like Adam. But
let's look at other uh another quote
from Ellen White that's problematic on
this topic. Um one that Steven's going
to skip over in this presentation while
quoting from these same pages that we're
going to read from here. She's
supposedly giving inspired commentary on
Genesis 3 here. This is Patriarchs and
Prophets page 53. And then we'll read a
follow-up quote on page 55. So
patriarchs and profits page 53
and then on page 55.
So she says the angel, this is again on
the creation account, the angels had
cautioned Eve to beware of separating
herself from her husband while occupied
in their daily labor in the garden. With
him, she would be in a less danger from
temptation than if she were alone. But
absorbed in her pleasing task, she
unconsciously wandered from his side.
Let me take off the little watermark
here as well.
On perceiving that she was alone, she
felt an apprehension of danger, but
dismissed her fears, deciding that she
had sufficient wisdom and strength to
discern evil to withstand it. Unmindful
of the angel's caution, she soon found
herself gazing with mingled curiosity
and admiration upon the forbidden tree.
The fruit was very beautiful. Let me
actually read off of this monitor over
here for you folks. I can make sure you
guys are seeing the same thing I'm
seeing. Yeah. Unmindful of the angel's
caution, she soon found herself gazing
with mingled curiosity and admiration
upon the forbidden tree. The fruit was
very beautiful, and she questioned with
herself why God had withheld it from
them. Now was the tempter's opportunity.
As if he were able to discern the
workings of her mind, he addressed her.
Yay, hath God not said, or rather, "Hath
God said, you shall not eat of of every
tree of the garden?" Eve was surprised
and startled as she thus seemed to hear
the echo of her thoughts. But the
serpent continued in a musical voice
with subtle praise of her surpassing
loveliness, and his words were not
displeasing. Instead of fleeing from the
spot, she lingered wonderingly to hear a
serpent speak. Had she been addressed by
a being like the angels, her fears would
have been excited. But she had no
thought that the fascinating serpent
could become the medium of the fallen
foe. So an angel supposedly came along
and told her, "If you wander away from
your husband, you're going to be
deceived." He's going to talk about this
portion, too. uh not that aspect but the
fact that the angels supposedly were
sent to reveal to Adam and Eve that a
powerful foe had fallen from heaven and
that he was going to be coming to the
garden to deceive them. So that's why
she's saying here had she been addressed
by a being like the angels her fears
would have been excited.
So then she goes into talking as we're
going to see about the serpent decided
to or the the devil decided to use the
serpent as a a me a medium a deceptive
miracle to make it look like the snake
was talking. but it wasn't actually him.
And uh he saw his opportunity was
perfect because she had wandered away
from her husband. Now, let's read this
second quote from page 55.
This is also the page, by the way,
folks, that we get the infamous,
"Whatever contradicts God's word, we can
be sure proceeds from Satan statement."
Um, but in the next paragraph, look at
what she says again here.
She says, 'The serpent plucked the fruit
of the forbidden tree and placed it in
the hands of the half- reluctant Eve.
Then he reminded her of her own words,
that God had forbidden them to touch it,
lest they die. She would receive no more
harm from eating the fruit, he declared,
than from touching it. Perceiving no
evil results from what she had done, Eve
grew bolder. When she saw that the tree
was good for food, and that it was
pleasant to the eyes, and a tree to be
desired to make one wise, she took the
fruit thereof, and did eat. It was
grateful to the taste, and she ate. She
seemed to feel a vivifying power, and
imagined herself entering upon a higher
state of existence. Without a fear, she
plucked and ate. And now, having herself
transgressed, she became the agent of
Satan in working the ruin of her
husband. In a state of strange uh
unnatural excitement, with her hands
filled with the forbidden fruit, she
sought his presence and related all that
had occurred.
So, scripture says Adam was with Eve.
Ellen says she wandered off and was
alone, got tempted, and then after
eating the fruit, took boatloads of it
in her arms to find her husband off
somewhere else and was used by Satan to
tempt and deceive him.
And this is right after we just got done
saying, "Whatever contradicts God's
word, we may be sure proceeds from
Satan." Which is right up here.
Whatever contradicts God's word, we may
be sure proceeds from Satan.
It's right there.
The irony. This talk is supposed to be
all about Satan's deceptions. Steven
quotes Ellen White saying, "Patriarchs
and Prophets was given to protect God's
people from deception after
contradicting God's word a mere sentence
prior." Meaning, by her own standard
found in the same book, her words are a
deception from Satan.
You can't make this stuff up, folks. And
this is only the beginning. He's going
to go into these pages we just looked
at. So, with this in mind,
we're laying a foundation here. Remember
what we just looked at and now watch the
flow of tonight and let's see
what all Stephen decides to get into.
God created Adam and Eve with every
spiritual and physical blessing. He gave
them fresh air, radiant sunshine,
luxurant emerald green fields, luxurant
plants, fragrant flowers, luscious
fruit, delicious sweet water, animal
companions, human companions, angel
companionship. And Adam and Eve had the
privilege of having face-toface
communion with their creator.
God by giving all of this to Adam and
Eve was revealing his love to them. Adam
and Eve did not earn any of this. It was
a sign of God's unmistakable love for
them. But God hoped that they would
return that love, that they would
reciprocate that love. You see, love is
a choice. God cannot order people to
love him. God did not create man to be a
puppet. He created him with a capacity
of reciprocating God's love. God the
lover wanted a response from Adam and
Eve.
And of course, they had to choose to
respond to God's love. Thus we find the
covenant formula already in the garden
of Eden. What is the covenant formula?
It is I will be their God and they shall
be my people.
But God decided to place a test in the
garden of Eden. I call this a test of
love. Adam and Eve had to choose to show
their love for God. And so God placed a
tree, the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil in the garden to test the love
and loyalty of Adam and Eve to him.
You know Jesus said, "If you love me,
you will keep my commandments." And so
God by placing the tree in the garden
was saying, "If you love me, you will
not eat from the tree."
So God hoped, this is an insight into
the Adventist God. For those that do not
know, he is a reactionary. He hoped man
would make a different decision. What
does it mean to hope for something? And
how does hope pertain to knowledge? Ask
yourself that. How how is hope how does
hope interact with a person's knowledge?
Hope assumes a lack of perfect
knowledge,
a certain level of ignorance to some
degree. Otherwise, you wouldn't be
hoping. You'd already be certain.
God did not hope that Adam and Eve would
make a certain decision and then they
didn't as though it was some sort of
shock to God. People like Steven Moore
will tell you God is omnisient, but then
they say stuff like this at the same
time. But as it pertains to the tree of
knowledge, um, sir, where does scripture
say it was placed in the garden as a
test of man's love for God? This is
again cut whole cloth for Ellen White.
Scripture nowhere says this. You're free
to believe it, but don't state it as a
biblical fact, especially since you guys
constantly claim that you only believe
the Bible. This is part of my concern
for SDAs. The line between Ellen White
and the Bible is blurred. Steven tries
supporting this by quoting one of the
SDA's favorite proof texts, John 14:15.
Jesus saying, "If you love me, you'll
keep his commandments." So, I want you
to notice something. It's okay for SDAs
to utilize uh inference, deduction, etc.
when they need to. Uh it doesn't have to
explicitly state what they claim. In
this case, the tree of knowledge of good
and evil was placed in the garden as a
test of man's love for God. But then if
you do the same thing on the other
topics, say the Sabbath, now all of a
sudden they resort to the verbatim
fallacy. There's not a single text in
the Bible that says to go to the church
on Sunday type arguments. This is one of
the major bones I have with SDA
theology. The inconsistency is all over
the place. Jesus' words in John 14 do
not prove that the tree was placed in
the garden as a test of man's love. This
is yet again Ellen White's assertion
that Steven is regurgitating. In fact,
he's going to get into Genesis 2 now,
and I want you to pay close attention to
what he says, and then we're going to
look at Genesis 2 and see how this idea
of a test uh matches up.
You will keep my command. Let's read
about that command in Genesis 2 and:es
15-17.
Genesis 2:15-17.
Then the Lord God took the man and put
him in the garden of Eden to tend and
keep it. And the Lord God commanded the
man, saying, "Of every tree of the
garden you may freely eat, but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
you shall not eat. For in the day that
you eat of it, you shall surely die."
Let me ask you, was God's command clear?
There was nothing ambiguous about it.
His command was clear. Was his command
simple?
Yes, it was not complex. God did not
give them a long list of rules and
regulations. Just one prohibition for
them to show their love and loyalty
toward him. Was the command easy to
obey? Of course, if they were hungry,
they could have eaten from any of the
trees of the garden. So, the command was
simple, clear, and easy to obey.
Um sir,
he said God did not give them a long
list of rules and regulations, just one
prohibition to show their love and
loyalty toward him. Stephen, Eve wasn't
there yet. Hadn't even been created yet.
This was given to Adam, says the Lord
God commanded the man. Eve wasn't
created until verse 21. This was God
instructing Adam. It was his duty to
relay this information to his wife as
the male federal head and spiritual
leader. This is again why in 1 Timothy
2, Paul roots the roles within the
church to the created order of Adam and
Eve. This is part of why Adam was not
deceived. He received the command
directly from God.
This is why consulting these extra
biblical writings results in a total
mess. They read the inspired commentator
to get all these extra details
supposedly and then read two or three
verses from scripture out of context and
think, "Wow, she's so amazing. She she
lines up perfectly with scripture and
connects the dots for us, which is what
Stephen's going to say later." When in
reality, she actually completely
distorts the story and contradicts
scripture
because Steven is teaching this through
the lens of Ellen White's writings. He
not only completely misses what is said,
but notice what else he missed as it
pertains to God hoping and the tree
being a test as was previously claimed.
Let's look at Genesis 2:15-1 17. Genesis
2:15-1 17.
The Lord God took the man and put him in
the garden of Eden to work and to keep
it. And the Lord God commanded the man,
saying, "You may surely eat of every
tree of the garden, but of the tree of
knowledge of good and evil, you shall
not eat. For in that day that you eat of
it, you shall surely die."
The command was given to the man. But
notice what God says regarding eating
from the tree.
He does not say
if you eat of the tree. He says, "For in
the day that you eat of it, you shall
surely die." God already knew what ad uh
what man well Adam and and Eve God
already knew what they were going to do.
There was no test.
God was saying when you eat from the
tree, you're going to die. Almost as if
God is omnisient and wasn't taken off
guard by this.
Or in a sense, God was prophetically
foretelling this to Adam. when you eat
of the tree, you're going to die.
A test implies God setting this up to
see what man would do, would or would
not do. They failed and then God had to
initiate a plan B. In fact, that's
precisely what Ellen White taught in
Spirit of Prophecy Volume 2 after the
fall of man. We've looked at this
before. She says the father held a
council to figure out the plan of
redemption and Jesus had to try and
convince him three times that he'd be
the one to go and ransom fallen man.
Again, the Adventist God is a weak
reactionary. Adam and Eve did not thwart
God's plans, folks. The fall did not
take place by or take, you know, taken
by surprise.
God's plan was working out exactly how
he intended. And no, you don't have to
think man is a robot to disagree with
the SDA narrative on this, which is the
typical caricature they're going to hurl
at you. Steven already said that this
test was at the behest of Adam and Eve,
not being puppets.
again it says something uh scripture
says nothing of of that. So let's get
back into this.
Now there's a very important point in
the story that we find in Genesis 1 and
two and that is that Adam and Eve as
evidence that they love God were to obey
God's command without explanations or
without God giving them any reasons.
Now, God told them what the consequences
would be if they ate from the tree. But
God did not tell them what was in that
specific tree, why God forbade it to
them. So God expected to them to obey
without any explanations. He wanted
unquestioning obedience to his command
as an evidence of their love for him.
Ellen White wrote in Patriarchs and
Prophets, page 53, the following words.
Should they attempt to investigate
its nature, that is the nature of the
tree, they would be exposed to his
wives.
They were admonished to give careful
heed to the warning that God had sent
them and to be content with the
instruction that he had seen fit to
impart.
Don't ask me why you can't eat from this
specific tree that according to Ellen
White looked like just the other trees.
It was just as beautiful. Simply take me
at my word and don't eat from the tree.
No explanations, no reason given. But
yes, the consequences if they ate from
the tree.
Where is any of that in the Bible?
We're going to be asking this on repeat
tonight. This movement emphatically
tells us like a broken record. They only
believe the Bible. No creed but the
Bible. Yet here we have Steven telling
us all sorts of details about the tree
of knowledge that the biblical text says
nothing about.
And this is how Ellen White functions
for them. Like I mentioned earlier, they
think that because she comments on
something that's found in the Bible, in
this case, the tree of knowledge of good
and evil, all the added details she
claims to have been shown aren't extra
biblical because the thing she's giving
details on is found in the Bible.
So, Ellen White will proof text a
passage, give all sorts of extra
biblical details, and then SDAs will run
with the proof text as the support for
the extra biblical details that aren't
found in the Bible.
She's just assumed to be correct. So,
you got that? She supposedly gives
inspired commentary and details about
stuff found in the Bible. And because
she's commenting on stuff found in the
Bible, that means they only believe the
Bible.
This is the sort of cognitive dissonance
that one lives in when you are an
Adventist. It's hard to describe if you
haven't been there, but that is what you
are seeing. They will tell you straight
to your face and many of them that yeah,
they're not cracking open Ellen White.
They do not understand it is a
worldview. It is not a biblical
worldview. It is an extra-biblical
worldview that is then being brought to
the Bible that the Bible is then being
read through like you're seeing here.
And people can b and scoff at at Steven
Borne and say, "Oh, he's a last
generation theology guy." That's the
logical conclusions of the theology. I
have more respect for these types than I
do the average SDA because these types
actually understand the systematics of
the system. They're pouring into this
and and they're arriving at the same
conclusions of things that people who
really are studying this system out
arrive at.
So he's a consistent Adventist. He's not
an alleart Adventist.
But let's continue here.
Furthermore, we find in the Genesis
story that God defined what is good and
what is evil. God was the arbiter, if
you please, of good and evil. The
standard of right and wrong was not
internal but external.
In other words, God defined what was
good and what was evil. This is totally
contrary to postmodern thinking where
the idea that you can define good and
evil is not given objectively by God but
comes subjectively from your own heart.
So we're going to find that Satan was
the first postmodern if you please in
the history of this world. Actually
Satan had already used this argument in
heaven. The argument that the definition
of right and wrong does not come from
outside in an objective source from God
but comes from inside that you define
good and evil yourself. He used the same
argument for the angels in heaven.
Notice great controversy page 499.
He that is Lucifer in heaven reiterated
his claim that angels needed no control
but should be left to follow their own
will which would ever guide them. Right?
He denounced the divine statutes as a
restriction of their liberty and
declared that it was his purpose to
secure the abolition of law that freed
from this restraint the hosts of heaven
might enter upon a more exalted more
glorious state of existence. He used the
argument angels don't need an external
source of right and wrong. They can
decide this on their own. They need no
control. Their own will will always lead
them to what is right.
Again, Stephen, where is that in the
Bible? We don't care about the great
controversy.
Where in the Bible does it say that
prior to the creation of the earth,
Satan made the argument in heaven that
right and wrong can be determined within
oneself and they need not look outside
themselves for that standard.
This is why it's laughable that this
movement claims to only believe the
Bible when their theology is steeped in
Ellen White.
This is a like foundational thing,
folks. You have to understand this is
part of their problem of evil situation.
How did evil get in the world? Well,
Satan was in heaven and he became
jemino. We've talked about this plenty
of times. Jesus was exalted to be made
equal with the father which triggered
Satan becoming prideful, etc. And then
downstream from that you have now he
starts saying God's a tyrant and
attacking the law of God and this is why
man fell and man was put on a period of
probation. All this stuff is connected.
So this stuff that he's saying here is
not just some like oh well you know you
don't have to have that detail. Yes you
do. You have to have all this stuff like
Satan was in heaven making this
argument. You really think Ellen White
was shown all this stuff by God more
than any other human being in all of
existence? This woman who was hit in the
head with a rock at 9 years old. And
they use that as support to say, "Well,
she wasn't even supposed to live."
Clearly, God preserved her for this
task.
Was revealed by God more than any other
person that's ever walked the earth. She
wrote millions of words claimed they're
all from God. All these extra details.
Was given vision and tour of the new
earth, current heaven. Oh, it was only a
vision. Yeah. Okay. Crazy, man. Like,
it's really about Ellen's writing Ellen
White's writings with her surplus of
details to then come to the Bible and
read it through the lens of their
system. The great controversy theme.
The Bible has very little to say about
Lucifer, Satan. But the Adventist
Church, if for those that don't know,
they think they know all sorts of stuff
about him. They're supposedly masters of
Satan. They know what his thoughts are,
things he said in heaven prior to uh the
earth being created, arguments he used
to deceive the angels, that he was the
choir leader with a large brow ridge,
almost like he's a human supposedly, and
and all these sorts of just other
details that the Bible doesn't say. Yet,
they want to lecture Christians about
the Bible, how to rightly handle the
Bible, and condescendingly tell you, if
you're a Christian, that unlike everyone
else, they only believe the Bible. No,
man. Y'all are kidding yourselves.
You're kidding yourselves. And former
SDAs can see through right through the
veil. It's transparent.
It's not even It would be like putting
Saran wrap over my face and insisting
that my tongue wasn't sticking out when
it is, thinking everyone else can't
clearly see my tongue is sticking out.
It is that transparent. It's like, dude,
when you're not in that world anymore,
it just
it's just plain as day. And then watch
what he's gonna say here, you know, in a
little bit.
Now, God had warned Adam and Eve that a
powerful angel had fallen from heaven
and that he was going to come to the
garden to try and convince them to eat
from the forbidden tree. Now, Eve
thought, well, if this angel comes from
heaven and tries to convince me to eat
from this tree immediately, I'm going to
know that this is the angel that God
spoke to us about. And so, Satan could
not appear as an angel of light. Let me
ask you, can Satan transform himself
into an angel of light? The Bible says
yes. But if he came as an angel, Eve
would detect him immediately. So, he had
to use camouflage. He had to use
deception. He had to hide his true
identity.
See, so that's what I mentioned earlier.
Where does the Bible say that God told
Adam and Eve that a powerful angel had
fallen from heaven and was going to try
and convince them to eat from the tree.
Again, cut whole cloth from patriarchs
and prophets and other Ellen White
writings. If you haven't figured out
yet, he's literally just summarizing
patriarchs and prophets, pages 53
through 56. Only periodically, he's
telling you when he's quoting. Go look
it up, egwritings.org,
and just put in pp space 53, and it'll
take you to paragraph one of page 53.
And just read through it. He's literally
just giving you a summary of patriarchs
and prophets, pages 53 through 56, only
periodically telling you that he's
quoting.
And then same thing with Spirit of
Prophecy Volume 2 starting on page 17.
That's another place that this is
discussed about. I think it's on page
17.
But nowhere does the Bible tell us what
Eve's thoughts were to this supposed
revelation.
This is patriarchs and prophets being
stated as though it's scripture.
So they just believe the Bible, right?
No creed but the Bible. the lion slander
Christians who they claim follow
tradition and not the Bible while
literally quoting Ellen White tfold in
comparison to the Bible.
Ellen White is their tradition. You know
the the old quote is so applicable here.
Those who say they have no tradition are
slaves to tradition. We all have
tradition folks. Everyone has a
tradition. Everyone has things that they
are being informed by that they are
bringing with them. It is a matter of do
those traditions align with scripture.
The classical Protestant argument was
tradition is reformable
against the infallible standard. But in
this case, that's not even possible in
Adventism because Ellen White's writings
uh correct inaccurate interpretations of
scripture.
You'll get Adventists that tell you,
"No, no, no. We don't think she's an
infallible interpreter. Okay, was she
wrong here?" Well, and then they're
going to start defending her. They'll
never admit somewhere that she's wrong,
but then tell you, "No, no, no. We don't
believe she's an infallible
interpreter."
Again, cognitive dissonance, a constant
state of cognitive dissonance. I do not
miss living in that world. It's so nice
to be able to just say, "Yeah, that's
wrong." And move along or correct or
change or whatever needs to be and not
have this mentality that we've reached,
we're the pinnacle of truth. We have
nothing else to learn because our
prophetus was supposedly revealed more
than any other human being on the face
of the earth. all these extra details
filling in the gaps as Stephen's going
to say later. Have you noticed the ratio
of Bible to Ellen White so far? I'll
give you a tally at the end because I
kept I've listened to this about three
times and I kept tallying.
Yeah, Stephen, again, where does the
Bible say that Eve thought to herself,
I'll recognize this angel if I see him,
but she was unaware he could transform
into an angel of light. Notice he asked
he he asked the rhetorical question.
Does the Bible say Satan can transform
into an angel of light? So he's
sprinkling in scripture to try and
support this extra biblical chain of
assertions.
Yes. The Bible says that Satan can
transform into an angel of light.
Nothing about that has anything to do
with Eve's thoughts
and Satan having to use camouflage
because God told Adam and Eve a powerful
angel fell from heaven.
For those that don't know too, by the
way, uh, Great Controversy is basically
just John Milton's Paradise Lost.
And it is an adaptation of that, if you
will, if you know what an adaptation is.
It's literally just an adaptation of
John Milton's Paradise Lost, which is a
book that is historical fiction. John
Milton didn't try and say, "God showed
me this. This is actual history."
He's doing an adaptation of the biblical
narrative as historical uh narrative to
or historical fiction to try and uh
make like just like a good author like
make like points essentially through
narrative. He's not trying to pass it
off as some real thing, but it's a story
from the fall from Satan's perspective.
That's literally what you're you're
getting here.
You're getting all this extra stuff
about Satan's thoughts and what he was
feeling and the arguments he was using,
yada yada.
The whole thing is predicated on Ellen
White's claim that angels are basically
human beings with wings, too. The
stereotypical depiction of an angel is
what Ellen White believes angels look
like because that's what she supposedly
saw. So, he's going to quote more from
uh Patriarchs and Prophets here. Let's
continue.
Patriarchs and Prophets, page 53. Ellen
White wrote, "Had she been addressed,
had Eve been addressed by a being like
the angels, her fears would have been
excited, but she had no thought that the
fascinating serpent could become the
medium of the fallen foe." And so, Satan
used camouflage. He hid himself by using
a serpent because he knew that Eve was
expecting an angel.
So, notice that, folks. This whole thing
is prior to the fall of man.
Eve apparently would have been fearful
in the unfallen state. A snake isn't a
fearful thing to unfallen man, but an
angel of light would be. Ah,
more extra biblical nonsense. Nowhere
does the Bible say that Eve's fears
would have been excited if Satan didn't
come in the form of a serpent. And
nowhere does the Bible say that Eve was
expecting an angel to appear in the
garden to tempt them.
Sir, where is any of this in the Bible?
Notice he's just quoting this as though
it is scripture, as though it's giving
you details that are not found in
scripture, but they're correct details
because God revealed them to Ellen
White, but they're not the Bible, right?
Even though it's God revealing them,
just like scripture is God revealing
that what makes it authoritative is the
the person uh by which it's coming from.
The reason scripture is authoritative is
because of the one doing the revealing,
which is God.
There's not levels where it's like, "Oh,
he revealed in scripture, but then he
revealed in Ellen White, but the the
stuff in Ellen White is is lower. It's
lower revelation." No, they view this
stuff just like they view scripture.
These really by the book Adventists like
Steven Bore.
Are you seeing why this is laughable,
folks? That they kind of only believe
the Bible. And this is like a classic
traditional Adventist sermon by a
serious SDA pastor who takes the the
system of theology seriously. Not I've
been influenced by Andy Stanley, so I'm
trying to be the cool church within the
Adventist stream and not this West
Coast, we're a big tent style Adventism.
No, no, no. just like the pioneers were,
just like they were until they've had to
do all these pivots to try and blend in
to to seem more friendly and more
ecumenical. Don't fall for that
nonsense. Don't fall for that. People
like Steven Boore, they are the
consistent ends of SDA theology. The
theologians and scholars of the movement
know it. People like Steven Boore, they
know it.
I mean, come on, man. He's literally
just reciting Ellen White's writings to
you and then sprinkling in proof texts
from scripture periodically that sound
like they support what Ellen White is
saying. No, give us a break.
Now, we're going to find in our study
that Satan used five methods to leave
lead Eve into sin and then through Eve,
Adam. The first thing that Satan did was
to perform a counterfeit miracle.
Is Satan going to use miracles at the
end of time to deceive the world? Yes.
Signs and wonders were told in Matthew
chapter 24 to deceive, if possible, even
whom? Even the elect. So, he performed a
counterfeit miracle. You say, "What was
the counterfeit miracle that he
performed in the Garden of Eden?" Well,
let's read Genesis chapter 3 and verse
one. Genesis chapter 3 and verse one.
Now, the serpent was more cunning than
any beast of the field which the Lord
God had made. And he said to the woman,
let's stop there for a moment.
Can serpents speak?
I assure you that if you went to a
serpentarium
and you were looking into a cage where
there was an anaconda and the anaconda
lifted its head and said, "Good
afternoon," you would be out of there in
a hurry. Serpents don't speak. However,
Satan made it look like the serpent was
speaking. That is a counterfeit miracle.
Eve knew that God had not given the
serpent the ability to speak. This is
where the temptation actually begins.
Notice this statement from Spirit of
Prophecy Volume 1, page 35.
But Eve was amazed,
for she knew that God had not given the
serpent the power of speech.
She knew it. God did not give the
serpent the ability to speak. And now
the serpent is speaking. So in her mind,
she's beginning to wonder why did God
lie to us?
How did the serpent learn to speak? Are
the thoughts that are coming to her
mind?
Where does the Bible say Satan made it
look like the serpent was speaking?
Again, Stephen, you do not know this.
Neither did Ellen White.
This is pure speculation and fantasy
that you're trying to pass off as being
biblical. The biblical text says nothing
about this. It says the serpent
communicated with Eve. Period. doesn't
say it was a counterfeit miracle he
performed to make it appear like the
serpent was talking but Satan was behind
a bush or something really doing the
talking. And the reason I'm being firm
on this is because they're the ones
folks that regularly use the standard of
we only believe the Bible and they pull
the verbatim fallacy.
Unless it's verbatim there,
they won't accept the new creation. You
know, the argument that the church has
understood for 2,000 years,
the from the biblical text for the new
creation memorial, which is the first
day, not the seventh day, because there
isn't a verbatim verse that says this.
Oh, but when Steven reads the spirit of
prophecy, none of this stuff is verbatim
there. But well, well, snakes obviously
can't talk. So, of course, it's a
counterfeit miracle, right? The text
doesn't say that.
That's the point. So stop using that
standard for other people and saying
that they can't deduce and use logical,
you know, faculties.
It's an inconsistent standard.
That's why we're holding them to the
fire on this. Again, they like to
condescendingly tell you very regularly,
we just believe the Bible. This this
fake piety,
but then they'll bring this to here's
what Eve's thoughts were. That's not in
the Bible, man. You don't know what her
thoughts were. You don't know that Satan
was just You don't know how the
mechanics behind any of that. This is
wanting to peek behind the curtain
and see more than what God has chosen to
reveal. That's what it's really about.
You want extra information that no one
else has because that appeals to your
flesh.
It's like a Gnostic sort of idea. I have
this like special knowledge and insight
that no one else has.
He quoted Spirit of Prophecy Volume 1,
page 45. That isn't the Bible, sir.
Nowhere does scripture say that Eve
started by asking the internal question,
why did God lie to us? This is
likenosticism. Again,
total extra biblical speculation and
deception. As we've already seen, Egyp
White said earlier, "Whatever
contradicts God's word, we can be sure
proceeds from Satan." as she
contradicted God's word twice in a mere
two pages prior.
Ellen White vividly described the
encounter of Eve with the serpent in the
Garden of Eden. Notice this passage from
Patriarchs and Prophets, page 53.
The fruit was very beautiful, the fruit
of the tree of knowledge of good and
evil. And she questioned, this is before
she begins a dialogue with the serpent
with Satan. She questioned with herself
why God withheld it from them. So she's
there under the tree. She's looking at
the tree. Why did God forbid us to eat
from this particular tree which is very
beautiful and the fruit is very
beautiful. She continues now was the
tempter's opportunity
as if very important expression as if he
was able to discern the workings of her
mind. As if the serpent was able to
discern the workings of her mind, he
addressed her, "Yay, hath God said, you
shall not eat of every tree of the
garden?" Eve was surprised and startled
as she thus seemed to hear the echo of
her thoughts.
So now she's saying to herself, "Not
only can the serpent speak, but the
serpent can read my thoughts."
But the serpent did not read her
thoughts. We're going to see in a
moment. So once again, Eve was surprised
and startled as she does seemed to hear
the echo of the thoughts. Her thoughts
were, "Why did God forbid from this
tree?" However, the serpent continued in
a musical voice with subtle praise of
her surprise surpass her surpassing
loveliness. And his words were not
displeasing. "Flattery will get you
everywhere."
Instead of fleeing from the spot, she
lingered wonderingly to hear a serpent
speak.
Was the serpent actually able to read
her thoughts? The answer is no. Notice
the explanation provided in the review
and herald February 24, 1874.
Eve was not aware that she had revealed
her thoughts by conser conversing to
herself.
So she came to I wonder why God told us
not to eat from this tree.
Eve was not aware that she had revealed
her thoughts by conversing to herself
aloud. Therefore, she was greatly
astonished to hear her queries repeated
by a serpent. She really thought the
serpent had a knowledge of her thoughts
and they must be very wise. So what has
happened up to this point? Both the
fruit and the serpent were beautiful.
The serpent was eating the fruit
according to the spirit of prophecy and
not dying. The serpent was able to talk.
So she's saying, "How did he learn?" The
serpent's voice was musical and pleasant
to hear. The serpent flattered her
because of her beauty. And she thought
the serpent could read her thoughts. You
see, the temptation was a process. It
was not a momentary event. It was a
process.
So the first method that Satan used was
to perform a counterfeit miracle.
Where does the Bible say any of that?
It's just like
no no
it's just so he read from the pages we
quoted from earlier patriarchs and
prophets. Eve thought the serpent knew
her thoughts because he repeated stuff
back to her that she had thought, but
she didn't realize she'd audibly
vocalized it.
So Eve, prior to being fallen, was an
idiot. Apparently, God gave her the
short-term memory of a goldfish.
Think about this. She was supposedly
thinking out loud. Satan heard her say
it, repeated what she said back to her,
and she thought, "How did the serpent
know my thoughts?" Completely ignorant
of the fact that she spoke out loud.
What a joke, Stephen. Where is this in
the Bible? Stop telling people you guys
only believe the Bible. You've quoted
Ellen White twice the amount of the as
the Bible so far and probably 10 times
the amount of words from Ellen White
versus God's.
Then again, you think that Ellen White's
words are God's words.
Also notice
Stephen quotes from a whole gamut of
Ellen White's writings, manuscript
releases, patriarchs and prophets,
review and herald. But if you're someone
that knows a large swath of her
writings, like yours truly, they'll try
and say you don't understand how her
writings properly function. They'll try
and act like you don't understand the
hierarchy of Ellen's writings and level
of authority as if there's some sort of
arbitrary standard that they've put
forth.
It's okay to quote from the whole
spectrum of writings, but only if you're
going to say something positive. Not if
you're examining with a critical eye,
like one should.
You know, it's okay for Adventist
pastors like Steven Boore and Ted Wilson
and Dr. O and Dwayne Lemon and Mark
Finley and Randy Ske and so on. It's
okay for them to quote from across the
gamut of her writings.
But if you quote from some of the
lesserk known writings as a critical
examiner, you're labeled as a clueless
critic who doesn't understand how her
writings function. How convenient,
right?
I've been hearing that for like 15
years. It's just it's such the like what
a desperate excuse.
You're going to see, man, if you watch
enough of this guy, he quotes from all
over the board. He understands the
statements we looked at during the
funeral service where she's saying it's
all from God or all of Satan. I haven't
written one single heretical sentence.
If you go against any of my writings,
you're going against the spirit of God.
And it just give me a break.
I just say that stuff to say be prepared
for this lazy excuse if you start
quoting her writings. Um, Adventist
Ellen White is the one who set the
standard up for herself that she never
wrote a single sentence of heresy. That
the words in her books are barricaded by
a thus sayeth the Lord. That it's all
from God or all from Satan.
That whatever contradicts God's word we
can be sure proceeds from Satan. Don't
give us this inconsistent standard that
doesn't even align with her own claims.
Now let's go to the second method that
Satan used. Genesis 3 and verse 1 once
again. Now the serpent was more cunning
than any beast of the field which the
Lord God had made. And he said to the
woman, "Has God indeed?" That means did
God really tell you, "You shall not eat
of every tree of the garden?"
What is the serpent doing?
Misquoting
God's word. He is adulterating God's
word because God had not said that they
could not eat from every tree of the
garden. God had said that they could not
eat from this particular tree. Correct?
Now, did the serpent know the command
that God had given Adam and Eve? Did he
know what God had said to Adam and Eve?
That they couldn't eat from this
particular tree? Of course. So, did the
serpent know that Eve knew? Of course.
And so, both the serpent and Eve knew
what God had said. So why did the
serpent why did Satan misquote God's
word knowing that Eve knew what God had
really said? The reason is simple. He
wanted to start a conversation.
There's no better way to start a
conversation than by making a wrong
statement.
For example, if I said to you, "This
coat is red."
I'm sure immediately you say see I I see
you saym
if I make a misstatement that the the
natural reaction of a human being is to
want to what is to want to correct the
wrong statement. The serpent wants Eve
to start a conversation with him. In
other words, so Eve immediately enters
into controversy. Eve says, "Oh, oh, I'm
going to correct you now. You got it
wrong." Notice Genesis 3 2 and 3. And
the woman said to the servant, "We may
eat the fruit of the trees of the
garden." In other words, you've made an
inaccurate statement. But of the fruit
of the tree which is in the midst of the
garden, God has said, "You shall not eat
it, nor shall you touch it, lest you
die." That's not what God said, right?
But she's she's trying to defend the
honor of God. She says, "God said, don't
eat it and don't touch it." Eve went
beyond what God had told him. She's
adding to God's word. In other words,
notice what he said.
The natural response when someone makes
a misstatement
is to correct it. But not when it comes
down white, right?
You're a critic. You're a hater.
You hate the law of God.
When someone misspeaks, he says the
natural response is to want to correct
it.
Yet Adventists will b and scoff at you
for critiquing Ellen White. You're
obsessed with Ellen White. Well, she's
misspeaking all the time. She's
contradicting God's word all the time.
The natural response is just to to
correct it. So there you go.
But again, Stephen, God gave the command
to Adam. Eve was not even created yet
when the command was given.
She inherited this from Adam as her
federal head.
God designed men, folks, to be the head
of their wives as Christ is the head of
the church. That doesn't look like what
a lot of people think that looks like,
by the way.
But the responsibility to spiritually
and physically provide for the wife is
on the shoulders of the husband.
But nevertheless, where does the Bible
tell us, sir, that Satan had the thought
that he wanted to start a conversation?
This is all inference, assumption, etc.
are from your extra biblical source of
authority. None of that is found in
Genesis 3:1. It simply says Satan asked
Eve a question. Nothing about his
thoughts, nothing about Eve's thoughts,
nothing about Eve being stupid, not
remembering that she spoke her thoughts
out loud and that's why Satan knew them
and repeated them back to her.
Again, we're using your guys's often
used verbatim fallacy.
It all has to be verbatim there in the
text, right?
That's the standard you use for other
doctrines when you're trying to argue.
I've heard him use it for the state of
the dead. I every time with the Sabbath
every every time.
Also notice how Ellen White's uh
descriptions of Adam and Eve or yeah,
Ellen White's descriptions of Adam and
Eve are like a fallen human being yet
they hadn't fallen yet.
He says, 'The natural inclination when
someone makes a misstatement is to
correct the wrong statement. We have
very little in scripture, folks,
pertaining to Adam and Eve's pre-fallen
condition, aside from the fact that they
were upright good and moral.
We don't know what the pre-fall
experience was like. If they had fears,
like if Satan appeared as an angel, but
a snake wouldn't scare Eve, etc.
This whole thing is written from a
standpoint of fallen humanity. And yet
Ellen is commenting on prefallen
humanity.
Notice the book Confrontation page 14.
This is a small book that came out
recently uh writing of Ellen White. Eve
had overstated the words of God's
command. He had said to Adam and Eve,
"But of the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil, thou shalt not eat of it.
For in the day that thou eatest thereof,
thou shalt surely die." E in Eve's
controversy with the serpent, she added,
"Neither shall ye touch it." So the
serpent is misquing God's word and Eve
is adding to God's word. And Ellen White
states that at that moment the serpent
plucked a fruit from the tree, put it in
the hands of Eve and said, "See, you're
touching it and you're not dying."
So notice he quotes from where we read
from earlier, page 55.
but conveniently leaves out the part
where Ellen contradicts scripture by
saying Eve was wandering alone without
Adam.
Nothing in the text, Stephen says
anything about the serpent plucking
fruit
says, "But the serpent said to the
woman, you will not surely die, for God
knows that when you eat of it, your eyes
will be opened. You'll be like God,
knowing good and evil." So when the
woman saw that the tree was good for
food, and that it was a delight to the
eyes, and that the tree was to be
desired to make one wise, she took of
its fruit and ate. And she also gave
some to her husband who was with her,
and he ate.
Where does it say the serpent plucked
fruit and put it in her hand and played
off of the fact that she added to God's
word? We're going to get back to that in
a moment.
That's the crux though of what God has
revealed for us about this interaction.
Nothing about Satan plucking fruit.
And as we saw earlier, nothing about Eve
being alone and then running off with
armfuls to find Adam,
which she actually mentions again on
page 58 um in paragraph 3,
which says, "Eve had been the first in
transgression, and she had fallen into
temptation by separating from her
companion contrary to the divine
direction.
[Music]
Nope.
Right there. Genesis 3:6, Adam was with
her plain as day.
And how ironic. He tells us Eve added to
God's word and adulterated it. Yet, he's
quoting and has quoted from a woman who
did the same thing 20fold.
Touching the fruit was a simple
deduction of what one would do by
touching it. You'd have to touch it to
eat it.
Steven Boore and Ellen White want us to
think Eve was adding to the word of God
here. Sure, let's grant them that.
Stephen, your prophetist did this 20
times over what Eve did.
Just in this presentation alone, you've
added entire scenes to the word of God,
creating contradictions.
I mean, come on.
In the same book, Ellen White claims
snakes were gold with wings prior to the
snake being cursed.
It was the most beautiful of all the
creatures. But apparently that isn't
adding to God's word. Even though Ellen
claimed the words in her books are from
God and apparently had hands and
opposable thumbs to pick the serpent
apparently had opposable thumbs to pick
fruit from trees.
Let's look at this, folks.
Look what she says here.
In order to accomplish his work
unpersceived, Satan chose to employ as
his medium the serpent, a disguise well
adapted for his purpose of deception.
This is what Steven's been been
mentioning. The serpent was then one of
the wisest and most beautiful creatures
on the earth. It had wings and while
flying through the air presented an
appearance of dazzling brightness having
the color and brilliancancy of burnished
gold
resting in the rich laden branches of
the forbidden tree and regalling itself
with the delicious fruit. It was an
object. That's what he's talking about.
The sn servant was eating the fruit too.
Apparently it was an object to arrest
the attention and delight the eye of the
beholder. Thus in the garden of peace
lurk the destroyer watching for his
prey. So, Satan is the serpent the way
it's being described here. But no,
that's not actually Satan. Satan's
behind a bush doing a ventriloquist job
making it appear like so he's able to
like be a puppet of a serpent that has
wings and he lurched it up in a tree and
then made the thing start eating fruit
as well.
He quoted from Ellen White's
Confrontation.
It's a I think relatively newer
compilation book from the White Estate.
It's still her words. It's just
compiled. Genesis 2 clearly says God
gave the command to the man Adam. Eve
hadn't even been created yet. It doesn't
tell you that later on God reiterated it
to Adam and again to Eve the first time.
So Ellen White is wrong.
Then the claim that uh Satan told Eve,
"You didn't know servants could speak,
did you?" more of Ellen White just read
into the scriptures and treated like
it's a bonafiday fact. Nope, not buying
it. In Adventism, it's just a given that
Ellen White is a prophet speaking from
God. No questions. You just have to take
the extra details provided full stop as
though they're God's words while at the
same time claiming to only believe the
Bible.
Nah, not buying. Not buying. I don't
care who it is. I don't care if it's
Ellen White, Joseph Smith, Mary Baker,
Eddie. I don't care who it Muhammad.
And then the serpent says to Eve, "You
didn't know that serpents could speak,
did you?" And he was thinking, "Well,
no, I didn't know." So the serpent is
saying, "Uh, do you want to know how I
learned to speak?" Notice once again,
Patrius and Prophets, page 54. Are you
understanding the process? I thank God
for the spirit of prophecy which fills
in the gaps and helps us see the methods
that Satan used because they're the same
methods that he's going to use at the
end and he is using now.
There you have it.
Says it all, folks.
Thank God for Ellen White's writings
because they fill in the gaps and
connect the dots to make sense of the
Bible. But you're only supposed to
believe the Bible, right? But she fills
in the gaps.
And that one guy with the white hair
behind Steven nodding his head that
mouth, "That's right."
Adventist, don't tell me you guys only
believe the Bible or that Ellen White is
she's only a commentator. No, folks, no
commentator through history, not even
the church fathers made claims like
Ellen White makes.
No biblical commentator was treating the
scriptures the way that Ellen White
does. They were commenting on what's
present in the text. Not adding in
supposed inspired details and then
saying, "God showed me all this,
therefore it's true."
That's not commentary. I could go
through the Bible and do this and fill
in the gaps and just insert all sorts of
stuff.
Hey, did you know that before the the
serpent got to the tree, it was actually
down by a brook? And down there, Adam
was where after Eve had separated from
him and he actually passed through there
and Adam almost stepped on him and
actually kept the serpent from being the
medium that uh the devil could use, but
he actually was able to get past Adam.
Doesn't contradict anything that's there
already in Genesis, right? That's what's
going on here. It's just filling in the
gaps.
Everyone before the SDAs came along were
confused, ignorant, didn't study the
Bible, which is why God had to give us
Ellen White's writings to supposedly
point people back to the Bible and give
the connecting dots to make sense of it
all using extra biblical means.
Are you starting to see this is why
precisely why I get so annoyed hearing
them parrot this after
my whole life I used to be one of these
people. We just believe the Bible. You
just repeat what you've heard because
they say it enough times.
We only believe the Bible or the I'm an
Adventist, but I've never read Ellen
White. I just believe the Bible. Yeah,
well, let's chat about it for five
minutes and do an analysis and see how
many Adventisms you hold to.
These extra biblical details that
Adventists oftentimes believe and think
are from scripture genuinely, but are
from Ellen White.
God allowed meat eating because of an
emergency. Where does Genesis 9 say
that? Oh, well, it's because all the
foliage died. Well, when at when Noah
sent a a dove out, it came back with an
olive branch.
Give me a break. These are little
Adventisms. These are things that are
not in the biblical text.
There's so many of these because this
woman through literary stealing and just
her own imaginations
just came up with all sorts of extra
stuff that's like no one can possibly
wade through this. You you have to read
people like Roy Gain and these scholars
in their church and take their word at
it because they're spending and Steven
Boore people who he's going to say it in
here.
He's constantly reading the spirit of
prophecy. Yeah, you'd have to when it's
10 times the length of the Bible and
some people spend their entire lives
trying to navigate through biblical
theology, let alone an extra two million
words of all these added details to the
the canon of scripture.
If you're an Adventist, I guarantee you,
if you're a former Adventist, I
guarantee you, you have Elanisms that
are littered throughout your theology. I
guarantee it. I'll still pick up on some
of them periodically.
mainly with esquetology with myself.
I'm like, hold up, hold up, hold up. And
it's been I've been out of Adventism now
for like 11 years.
The Adventist system of theology is the
writings of Ellen White with
supplemental support from the Bible in
the form of proof texts pulled from all
over the Bible. It is not a systematic
exposition of any given passage, walking
through the whole passage, verse by
verse by verse. It's this sort of
jumbled mess of extra biblical SDA
teaching intermingled with proof texts
which leave SDAs completely confused and
thinking they only believe the Bible.
And most SDAs are sincere when they say
this. But I'm sorry folks, it's not
true. This is a perfect example of why.
Even if they're not like Steven Boore
where they're constantly stating this is
from patriarchs and prophets or they're
quoting from Ellen White, I am telling
you they were trained in these
institutions from the systematic
position of the great controversy theme.
I don't care if they're your evangelish
style SDA pastor all the way to your
liberal guy. I don't care. It is the
great controversy worldview that unites
all of these people and the day they go
to church because beyond that, shoo,
you are going to get all sorts of
opinions. Jesus isn't divine. The
Trinity is not true. The Trinity is
true. Jesus is divine. The Holy Spirit's
not a person. The Holy Spirit is a
person. No, the health message isn't
serious. Yeah, the health message is a
life ordeath issue. The investigative
judgment is not one of the pillars.
Yeah, it is. It's part of Revelation
14:7. Well, no, that I mean, dude, it is
a jumbled mess. It is this that unites
them, the great controversy theme. And
that is not coming from the Bible. That
is coming from Ellen White.
It informs why they think Jesus came. It
involves what what role they think the
law plays. It it everything why man
fell, what's going to happen in the
future. It's all about this supposed
great controversy playing out between
Christ and Satan, which started because
Jesus was given authority and exalted to
be made equal with the Father, which
made Lucifer jealous.
Them's the facts, Jack, we've looked at
this countless times on the channel. If
you want to come on here and you're an
Adventist, email me answering
adventism@gmail.com.
And you want to come on here and defend
that anytime. If you think I'm taking
that out of context, like they always
say, come on to the show. Let's see
who's done their homework. Remember in
grade school how you just show your work
when you turned your stuff in? Or I
guess high school too, maybe.
I'm ready to show my homework anytime.
Are you?
Because you can't have this whole great
controversy theme without the first
domino.
You can try all the excuses. Oh, I
folks, we've been there.
Been there, done that, got the t-shirt.
I was there a while ago, but there are
people I've talked to. I talked to a
person last week who just left like two
weeks ago
trying to navigate through all this
theological fog that's been poured in on
them by this system. And then they're
left spiritually orphaned. That's what
Answering Advent is going to be, folks.
We got big announcements coming up, by
the way.
Going to need your guys' support on
that. But we're going to be a voice for
the millions of 7th Day Adventists
who've been spiritually orphaned by this
movement, spiritually abused in some
cases by this movement. Not all people
had that experience. I didn't have that
sort of experience,
but a lot of people, a number of people
did. They've never been heard. They get
slandered. They get lied about. They get
told, "You didn't know the police. You
It's just all dismissive."
So, we're going to be a voice for those
people. We're going to be a big
megaphone for them. But that's not all.
There's there's lots of other stuff. But
this is why there's all this theological
fog. These people are spiritually
orphaned after this. And then they're
left with all these Adventisms,
completely confused, oftentimes
considering walking away from it all,
associating all with Adventism, meaning
associating Christianity with Adventism.
And they shouldn't because it's not.
It is its own thing with its own
worldview. And this is the way it makes
itself known.
So again, whether your pastor is
preaching from this or not, and you even
are not hearing the name Ellen White
from the the pulpit, I understand. I've
been in like 1,500 different SDA
churches in terms of visiting, growing
up with my dad being an SDA pastor. I
know what you're saying. Yeah, she's
never mentioned. The worldview is the
same, folks. That's the way the pyramid
works in Adventism. We talked about this
before at the top of that river you have
the theologians the Roy gains the the
general conference who Ellen White again
another reason they're not solos
scriptura she said when the GC session
when the GC is in session it's the
strongest governing body on the face of
the earth and that what they have the
authority to come up with decisions and
you are to yield your opinion and
beliefs to what they say
that's who's at the top of this thing.
That trickles down to the professors,
the other theologians, etc.,
which is then trickling down to their
students,
theology students, etc., and the
pastors.
Ministry magazine is one of the arms
that they'll have for their clergy that
they use to send this stuff out that the
scholars and stuff have been discussing
higher upstream.
The people at the pastoral level in this
movement are salesmen.
It's how good of a salesman can you be
for the great controversy worldview and
do it in your your way, your style.
My dad is nothing like Steven Boore. But
they're coming from the exact same
worldview.
Exact same worldview.
He never mentions Ellen White from the
pulpit.
He's one of these like I was he was
influenced by Morris Vindon types.
same worldview. You're going to get the
same fundamental things. It's just
presented to you in a different way that
resonates with some people more than
others. But at the top of where this is
all coming from, it is the same. There
is no getting around this folks. You
cannot have Adventism without the great
controversy worldview. It is the great
controversy worldview that informs the
three angels messages. You have to have
all these extra details that fill in the
gaps because you can't make sense of all
this stuff. Show us in Revelation
Adventist where it says there's going to
be a national Sunday law headed up by a
three-fold union between the United
States, the papacy, and apostate
Protestantism that's going to enact an
intera or national turned international
Sunday law where Adventists are going to
be hunt. None of that is there. You have
to have all these extra details and then
find your proof text to just insert all
this stuff in there. You can't have it
without the great controversy worldview
because it's ultimately going to come
down to a day as Stephen's going to talk
about. All this stuff is connected,
folks. Avenous, it's time to give this
up. It's time to give this up.
You're being hoodwinkedked. You're being
bamboozled. You've been sold a bill of
goods.
We've been there. Millions of people
have been there. We do not hate you. We
don't just have an axe to grind. We were
there.
It is not biblical. It's not
Patriots and prophets page 54. By
partaking of this tree, he that is Satan
the serpent declared they would attain
to a more exalted spear of existence and
enter a broader field of knowledge. He
himself had eaten of the forbidden fruit
and as a result had acquired the power
of speech.
Oh, he is. Now, what is the serpent
trying to do? He's trying to shake the
confidence and trust of Eve in God,
particularly in the word of God.
Where in the Bible does it say the
serpent ate from the tree and then told
Eve he had done so and gained the power
of speech as a deception.
This is a good practical example, folks,
for what they mean again by they only
believe the Bible. They think that
because the baseline that the serpent
being a deceiver is found in the text,
they can read all these other details,
claims, etc. into the text and they're
just being biblical.
They'll try and act like what Ellen
White is doing here is nothing more than
Bible commentary.
Except again, no. Biblical commentators
comment on what's present in the text,
not adding a bunch of extra insight that
they're claiming is coming from God
that fill in the gaps and then claim if
you go against him, you're going against
the spirit of God in danger of ending up
in predition. You remember the funeral
stream, folks? She said you risk ending
up in predition if you reject her. That
is the first step in eventually leading
to predition. She says if you reject her
writings, you'll then eventually reject
the Bible and eventually just end up in
predition. Cultlike stuff.
So when you hear them use this mantra
and oh, we only believe the Bible.
Understand what in what that means.
Understand what that means.
The third method that Satan used was to
lead Eve to follow her impressions.
One other thing actually that I just
remembered or thought of
He's talking about or Ellen White's
talking about. Notice the flip-flopping
here. The devil's behind a tree or
behind a bush somewhere doing a
ventriloquist act manipulating the
serpent. No, Adventist. I know she
didn't say he's literally behind a bush.
By the way, I'm being pedantic.
Doing a ventriloquist act on the
serpent, but then acting as though it's
Satan that's eating the fruit.
saying, "See, I ate it and didn't die."
Remember, it's just a ventriloquist act.
Nowhere does the text say that the
serpent ate from the tree,
her intuition, her feelings, and her
logic. Let's go back to Genesis chapter
3 and verse 4. The most dangerous lie
that Satan has ever told. Genesis 3:4,
the serpent now has Eve where he wants
her. She's defended the honor of God.
And she said, "God has said that if we
eat from this tree, we're going to die."
And then Satan, the serpent, says, "You
will not surely die.
God is lying to you."
And what is he thinking?
Why did God lie to us? You see now Eve
has what is called cognitive dissonance.
A very simple word is confusion. Her
mind is confused. God has said that if
we eat of the fruit of the tree, we're
going to die. But now the serpent says,
"You will not surely die."
The serpent boldly insinuated that God
was lying to them. And even eve wanted
to know the reason why God had lied to
them. And Satan knew that he wanted to
know that. You see, Satan has the
uncanny ability to plant questions in
our minds and then to provide the answer
to the question that he planted in our
mind.
So, Eve is thinking, if we're not going
to die, why did God say that we're going
to die? What ulterior agenda could God
have?
So, Satan plants the question, why did
God lie to us? And then he provides the
immediate answer to the question that he
planted.
Genesis 3:5.
For God knows.
You see, Eve, God knows something that
he doesn't want you to know. God knows
that in the day that you eat it, that
you eat of it, your eyes will be opened.
Now, folks, Eve had 2020 vision
physically. The serpent is not saying
suddenly you were blind and now you're
going to see physically.
In the Bible, eyes represent wisdom and
understanding. In Ephesians chapter 1
and verse 18, it speaks about the eyes
of your understanding. When God called
Saul of Tarsus, who became Paul to be a
messenger to the Gentiles, God said,
"I'm going to send you to open the eyes
of the Gentiles." And of course, what
animal today is a symbol of wisdom? An
owl. Why? Because the owl has big eyes,
right?
For those that have this open on
your end,
patriarchs and prophets,
are you seeing how he's literally just
quoting verses periodically from the
Bible and then is paraphrasing or
verbatim citing Ellen White? It's
literally just a pariting of her book
without stating every time he's quoting
from her.
The people in the room are are basically
hearing Ellen White story hour.
And then they'll leave from something
like this
emphatically asserting that they only
believe the Bible genuinely and
seriously.
It's almost like when you're in this it
it just like it doesn't even connect
that
you do you just take what's being said
like oh man that that sermon is just
this is not how how biblical exesus and
and the office of sacred desk functions
folks
commentary is not to be is not supposed
to be preached through
commentaries are a study tool to see
what others are arriving at
to show you're not arriving at your own
private interpretation. It doesn't work
that way. It's not just your Bible and
you under a tree.
But furthermore,
preaching is when the pastor, the exede
is going through verse by verse by verse
by verse through the scriptures
expounding upon what the author's
intended meaning was.
That is the call of the pastor
outside of character qualifications.
It's being able to rightly handle the
word of God. That's the one skill like
that that is required. Everything else
is a character qualification.
This is not preaching.
It is literally just this guy reading
patriarchs and prophets sprinkling in
Bible verses where Ellen White does. by
the way, and he's just regurgitating it
out to you and presenting it as a good
ortor.
They will b and scoff.
SDAs will b and scoff at the pagan
Sunday Christians, some SDAs.
They'll b at people like my pastors
that preach through the text verse by
verse expounding upon the actual
language of the text in its original
languages. Sometimes referring to a
commentator or church father to showcase
like I said that it's not their own
private interpretation. But many others
for centuries have arrived at the same
conclusions.
You know, pastors who reserve the
proclamation from the sacred desk to be
God's word in its fullness, richness,
and power.
No, no. The SDA church will call that
being a slave to tradition, which really
just means um we understand Christianity
is a historical religion and that you
can't denute it from history and start
it in the 1800s with the Adventist
Church,
which is exactly what they've done, by
the way, folks. They're not formally a
part of the restorationist movement.
But the mentality 100% there just like
Mormons, just like Church of Christ,
just like all the groups from that time
who who make this claim. We're the
restoration of the one true church. The
fullness of the truth fell away. God
raised us up to restore it. That's the
the the uniting factor amongst all of
them. And that's exactly what the SDA
church teaches.
So the Bible has to be denuted from
previously.
You even mention a church father to an
Adventist and they immediately have in a
visceral response say, "Well, that's not
scripture. I didn't say they were
scripture."
Christianity is a historic religion.
Just because you're quoting someone
doesn't mean you believe that they're
infallible.
We quote tradition at least Protestants
do
to often show or build upon theology
that sometimes is like so for example
Nicholas Bound he was a a lesserk known
reformer. He dedicated pretty much the
most of his theological studies to his
treatise on the true doctrine of the
Sabbath.
If you don't have that book by the way I
highly recommend it. The true doctrine
of the Sabbath by Nicholas Bound. He
absolutely just I mean it's a pretty
scholarly work so it's not going to be
like a um like a super like simple read.
It's a very girthy, but if you're really
serious about that, he starts all the
way back at the the with the apostles
and scripture and then shows how the
understanding through the centuries
has been built upon by Christians
through the ages who have who have been
studying the Bible,
pouring over the Bible, doing biblical
theology, real hermeneutics, real
exesus, working with the original
languages. is
showing that there's a consistent thread
here. That's why Protestant theologians
are oftentimes like Calvin, Luther
are often quoting from church fathers to
show this isn't our own private
interpretation of this. They're not
saying that they're infallible.
Rome has an infallible tradition. That's
exactly what part of the issue was
around soloscripura, what we were
talking about at the beginning.
was basically that well no tradition can
can be wrong and we need to correct with
the God breathed scriptures the only God
breathed source that we've been given.
That was the argument. It wasn't throw
out all of tradition. They were all
pagan heretics. None of them understood
anything. What are you talking about?
What?
It's just craziness, man.
So they'll b and scoff at our pastors.
Yet some of their pastors get up on
stages and verbatim quote Ellen White
with four verses from Genesis, leaving
out biblical details like Eve being with
Adam not wandering
as you'll see.
And then he replaces those details with
Ellen White's imaginings. Leaves out
biblical details, fills it in with the
fill in the gap details. Again,
it's just I I just think about this,
man, and I I bring this up a lot on
here, and I'm going to brag on these
guys because they wouldn't for
themselves. I'm not obviously going to
say their name or anything like that,
but my pastors, serious men of God, a
blessing to the Christian church.
Serious like blessing to the church.
Just they just finished preaching
through First John this past Lord's Day.
There wasn't a single verse in the whole
book that wasn't preached, executed, and
connected to the flow of the text as
well as scripture as a whole.
Quoted other commentators and stuff
throughout. Yep. Not like this, but to
show there's been a plethora of people
as God has been leading the church in
working through these things who have
come to these understandings. Whether it
be the church fathers
through the medieval period, reformers,
Puritans,
they've done this with first John,
Ephesians, Colossians, uh, Habacook, uh,
Phileiman, Deuteronomy, Revelation, and
so on. They don't hopcotch around
quoting a couple proof texts here and
there from scripture and then fill it in
with 95% of John Calvin's commentary or
St. Chrysum's homalies.
Yet to downplay Ellen White, many
Adventists will tell you that they only
the church only views Ellen White the
same way as Christians view other
commentators. No, not even close.
He mentioned cognitive dissonance.
The irony.
Cognitive dissonance is also not simply
confusion,
folks. Cognitive dissonance is when
behavior does not match up with a
professed belief.
It is a process of confusion and logical
conflict. It's produced when a person is
presented with new information that
conflicts with already existing
information. So the classic example that
people often use is or or use is um
smoking cigarettes.
So though cigarette smokers know that it
will kill them and is harmful to one's
health, they continue smoking.
The cognitive dissonance for the smoker
is the uneasy tension they feel knowing
their behavior does not match up with
the profession about health.
This is Adventism to a tea.
It is a constant state of cognitive
dissonance.
I've witnessed it I don't know how many
times I was there. new information is
presented to them that contradicts their
deeply held beliefs. They have no
response for it because they know what's
being said is valid and they can't
refute it. So, they have to pivot off of
it and try and move to something
different. They develop an uneasy
tension, if you will. That shakes and
tugs at their these deeply held
theological beliefs that in the SDA
world is the pinnacle of truth.
They have nothing else to learn. Ellen
White had inspired guide on every
theological topic. had more revelation
given to her than anyone else in all of
human history
was shown more than anyone else
regarding people's thoughts including
Satan ees an entire pre-earth origin
story which is really just like I said
John Milton's paradise lost and
basically borrowing some concepts as
well from Mormonism which preceded them
all these details about heaven
everything in between this heck this
stream will give some SDA's cognitive
dissonance
Like the fact that Genesis 3:6 says Adam
was with Eve, yet Ellen claims she was
off alone, had wandered away, and then
went and found him after eating and
taking armfuls of fruit to him to be
used by Satan. Blatant contradiction.
Adam wasn't deceived. Ellen White says
Satan deceived Adam.
It is cognitive dissonance to then have
to go on a treasure hunt
of figuring out, okay, how do we defend
this at all costs? The elephant in the
room is she's wrong, folks. That's the
elephant in the room. It's not lowering
down the biblical writers to make sense
of her plagiarism. It's not lowering
down the biblical writers to well, the
apostles said the same thing. It No,
they didn't. I heard that one here
recently again for the eenth time
regarding the shut door.
Well, Peter said the door was shut to to
Gentiles. Ellen was the same way. So if
if Ellen's wrong, Peter's wrong. No,
Peter did not claim, "God told me the
Gentiles can't be saved." And then it
like a year later, he says, "Okay, God
showed me now they can be saved."
That's called equivocation, folks.
Conflating two things up against one
another that are completely different.
She claimed God showed her this. None of
the apostles claimed to speak on behalf
of God and did so falsely. You're
essentially saying, "Well, the apostles
broke the third commandment. The
apostles the apostles bore God's name
falsely, too." Again, it's a creative
way to try and elevate Ellen White by
diminishing the apostles.
Not going to work. Not going to work.
SDA apologists, y'all got to do better.
Not going to work. It's not going to
work.
telling you there are going to be SDAs
that have cognitive cognitive dissonance
about this. Go check the comments after
this stream is over. Watch. Watch. Well,
no. Here it was. There's two cases of
deception. It'll be they'll come up with
anything. That is the sign of cognitive
dissonance. Give it up, folks. By her
own standard, whatever contradicts God's
word, we can be sure proceeds from
Satan. That is the result of cognitive
dissonance.
It isn't just a person being confused.
If one were to preach through the
biblical text verse by verse by verse
and not in sound bite proof text with a
dump truck full of Ellen White, you'd be
able to see how this fictional account
completely twists scripture,
right? And so what is he saying? He's
saying God wants you to be blind to a
certain reality that he has not revealed
to you. He didn't tell you why you
couldn't eat from this tree, right?
Are you understanding this process?
God had not explained the reason why
they couldn't eat from that tree. And
now Satan is explaining in his mind the
reason why. So he says, "For God knows
that in the day that you eat of it, your
eyes will be open. Your understanding
will be open. You'll gain wisdom that
God didn't want you to have because he
wanted you to to be blind. And you will
be like God. Not like God in every
sense, but like God in a particular way.
And you will be like God what? Knowing
good and evil.
You don't have to depend on God to know
what is good and evil. If you eat from
the tree, you will be able to define
good and evil yourself without obeying
God's explicit command. So what the
serpent is saying is God is hiding some
valuable information from you. He has an
agenda. He wants you to render him blind
service. He does not want you to know
the real reason why he told you not to
eat from the tree. God keeps secrets and
there is an agenda behind his secrecy.
At this point, Eve is thinking to
herself, "Tell me more. What is God
hiding? Tell me the reason why God
threatened that we would die if we're
not going to really die. I want to
know."
Notice what Ellen White wrote in
Patriots and Prophets, page 54.
And he insinuated,
the serpent insinuated that the Lord
jealously desired to withhold it from
them lest they should be exalted to
equality with himself.
So what does he say?
At some point in the past, God ate from
this tree and it gave him his God
powers. But after he got his God powers,
he didn't want anybody else to have
them. And so he intimidated with the
idea that if they ate from the tree,
they were going to die. But really his
fear was that they would have the same
powers that he had. Let me complete the
statement. He insinuated that the Lord
jealously desired to withhold it from
them lest they should be exalted to
equality with himself. It was because it
because of its wonderful properties,
imparting wisdom and power that he had
prohibited them from tasting or even
touching it. He's repeating what she had
said. The Temprian intimated that the
divine warning was not to be actually
fulfilled. It was designed merely to
intimidate them.
We're going to respond to a comment here
first before we uh respond to what
Stephen said.
Uh let's see here.
Rodney, my man, this was a perfect
example here for what I was just talking
about. He says, "You're wrong." Speaking
about me, if Adam was with Eve at the
time, why is there no conversation
involve conversation involving him and
the serpent? Rodney, the biblical text.
So when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food, and that it was a delight
to the eyes, and that the tree was to be
desired to make one wise, she took of
its fruit and ate. And she also gave
some to her husband,
who was with her, and he ate.
I'm letting the word of God soak over
you, sir.
Wake up.
Wake up, sir. The alarm clock is
sounding.
This is spiritual warfare, folks.
Rodney, it's right there. It's right
there. Asking the question. Well, I know
it says it right there, but why wasn't a
conversation had? And why? You're
following the path now that that Stephen
laid out earlier of the serpent. You're
trying to go beyond what is written,
what God has revealed. Wake up, sir.
It is right there.
Do you believe the text?
This is a perfect example for you folks.
Rodney, you're experiencing cognitive
dissonance. It's dawning on you that
Ellen White does not pass the test.
The alarm clock is sounding, sir. It's
time to wake up.
I don't know how else to say it to you
Adventists. This is why folks, this is
exactly why I am so stern sometimes.
People need a stern waking up.
Are you seeing this is the sort of thing
I've been interacting with for I don't
know how long. They don't care what the
text says. They have to make Ellen White
work.
He said if Adam was with her, he was. It
says right there, she also gave some to
her husband who was with her and he ate.
This is why I was saying earlier,
this is why I was saying earlier
that Adam failed in his role as federal
head. There is a whole theology around
federal headship.
It's like this friend, God told them not
to eat of it. Had Adam been right there
with her, he would have he would have
had warned her. That's exactly the
point, Rodney. He failed in his role as
a man.
That's the point. He was there and he
should have been protecting her, but he
wasn't.
There is no I'm just again, Rodney, I'm
going to let the word of God base over
you because it's only the word of God
that has the power of God behind it.
It's right there, my friend. It's not
going to change.
It's not going to be any different.
It says it right there. Adam was with
her and he ate too. That was my point. I
don't know if you were here at the
beginning. This gets into headship. The
fact that we see a glimpse of where Adam
was failing prior to eating the fruit
himself.
He should have been protecting his wife.
Instead, he was passive.
The idea that God didn't reveal to us
through scripture that a whole
conversation went on back and forth does
not then negate the fact that it says
Adam was with her. You can't have these
extra details, sir, that contradict what
is clearly explicitly stated in the
text.
But back to what Steven Bore was saying,
more insight into Eve's thoughts
supposedly. Stephen, I hate to break it
to you, but you do not know what Eve's
thoughts were simply because you're
reading from patriarchs and prophets.
Satan supposedly told Eve that at a time
in the past, God ate from the tree and
became God, so they too can do the same.
Is that what the biblical text says?
More inspired details filling in the
gaps.
Remember, he previously said that Ellen
White said that the serpent was eating
the fruit and nothing bad was happening.
Now, the serpent is supposedly telling
Eve moments later that God ate from the
tree, which is how he became God.
So, Eve apparently was too stupid to
deduce that the serpent ate the fruit
and didn't become God, but God did,
which is how he became God.
Eve in the pre-fallen state was
apparently an idiot.
She didn't realize she was thinking out
loud, which is why the serpent appeared
to know her thoughts. And now she can't
connect the dots between God eating the
fruit and becoming God, which is what
the serpent said. Yet the serpent she
watched eat and didn't become God.
These are the sorts of issues, folks,
that arise when you start adding to
God's revelation and think you have a
bunch more on top of it that isn't
actual revelation.
The deadly camouflage is patriarchs and
prophets.
Or in the friends or in the words of my
friend EJ Thunder Lurston,
the Adventist movement hiding in plain
sight.
That's the deadly camouflage.
Lucifer had already done this in heaven.
Notice Patriots and Prophets page 37.
Speaking about Lucifer in heaven, he
began to insinuate doubts concerning the
laws that govern heavenly beings.
Intimating that though laws might be
necessary for the inhabitants of the
worlds, angels being more exalted needed
no such restraint, for their own wisdom
was a sufficient guide.
You will know good and evil. God doesn't
have to tell you what is good and what
is evil. That's why this is the first
postmodern of human history. He's saying
that the standard of right and wrong is
not outside of you in the word of God.
The standard of right and wrong comes
from within. You define what is right
and what is wrong. Is the world c uh
categorized like this today? Absolutely.
The standard in the world today is
inside. So everything the serpent is
saying is logical.
It it appeals to her impressions and her
feelings and her emotions and logic. But
it's false logic. It appears logical but
it's based on a lie. Now let's go to the
fourth method
book chapter and verse Stephen
that Satan started spreading doubts
concerning the laws that govern heavenly
beings.
This is foundational to the great
controversy worldview.
Central to the whole thing. Lucifer
supposedly began attacking God's law,
saying it wasn't fair. God's a tyrant.
And this led to war breaking out in
heaven. So again, the war in heaven, the
perfect example of how they'll read a
passage in scripture that simply
mentions something, in this case, war in
heaven. And then poured in all sorts of
Adventisms like Lucifer attacking the
law of God, saying his law isn't fair.
None of that's in the Bible.
God has chosen to reveal very little
about Satan, let alone his thoughts,
statements, etc.
The reality is the Adventist church is
not satisfied with God's word as we just
saw from our friend.
They're not satisfied with God's word.
But these same people will tell you, "We
only believe the Bible." Yet then they
have to defend, "Well, no, Adam wasn't
there. There had to have been a
conversation." None of that's in the
Bible. So, no, you don't believe just
the Bible.
The Bible is not enough for them. They
need more. They want to peek behind the
curtain.
They want special insight beyond what
God has chosen to reveal in scripture.
Again, this is like Gnosticism.
It appeals to your flesh. It isn't just
with Adventism, by the way. There's all
sorts of groups out there. There's lots
of esque esqueological groups that have
this sort of thinking. They think
they've cracked all the codes. They know
every symbol, sign, number, and they can
give you all these things that everyone
else has missed out on.
Folks, the reality is is the Christian
faith is historic. It's not to say that
there's not building upon things that
take place and and errors that creep in
or errors that happen,
but that is not what's going on here.
This is an entire foreign biblical
worldview where the Bible is just a
supplement
to try and use as a veil over this other
stuff.
Well, see it it it says that Adam ate
and because he would have stopped Eve
from eating the fruit, that means there
had to have been a conversation where he
wasn't present, even though the text
explicitly says he was with there and he
he was with her there and he ate too.
He also mentioned Satan being the first
postmodern in human history. Yet he yet
he just mentioned that he was uh this
way in heaven prior to human creation.
this started with with Satan. Well, they
have a whole pre-earth origin story.
Long before the earth was created, long
period of time. Who even knows how long?
And he mentioned logic again,
which is rather ironic because based on
what he's presented thus far, Eve
clearly wasn't engaged in logic like at
all.
Speaking her thoughts out loud, then
speaking back to
Yeah.
kind of like this narrative from Ellen
White,
not logical. It's false logic.
It's based on a lie.
It is the deadly camouflage that is the
poison of the mind over
who knows how many people in the room
that are hearing them shield this up.
Sad.
I think about how many former SDAs I
talked to struggle separating these
elanisms from actual biblical theology.
It starts at cradle roll
like the earliest possible age if you're
raised in this. You read all these extra
things. The the story of Daniel is about
a prescription of a vegetarian diet
because Daniel was a vegetarian even
though it says if you continue reading
to Daniel 10 from Daniel 1 that uh he
only abstained for three weeks because
uh he was doing a fast and it actually
has nothing to do with Daniel's
prescriptive diet because Daniel
actually would have eaten lamb during
the Passover because he was a Jew.
It just all these sorts of little things
that you then start plugging in and
taking to the Bible not realizing they
are not in the text
and then people struggle with these when
they leave and they're just having to
decipher through all this. I call it a
theological fog.
That's what we're watching here. It is a
bunch of impressionable pe people in an
impressionable state having their minds
polluted with all this extra biblical
fog.
Confusion leaving them twice worse than
when they walked in.
spiritual warfare, folks. Sewing seeds
in their minds that will continue to be
watered by this movement and grow into
theological vines of ivy
that just spread throughout the mind
binding it in a strangle hole
just gradually over time just watering
in just watering in. Notice how many
words to scripture have been cited
tonight.
So much subtle just twisting omission
double speak.
Now get this. For those that have been
watching who had patriarchs and prophets
who brought it up,
notice what portion of those pages
between 53 and 56, he skipped over.
And now let's listen to to what he says
here.
Satan led Eve to follow the testimony of
her five senses.
Had she heard the words of the serpent?
Her ears are involved.
Did she see the fruit and it was
beautiful? Yes. Did it look tasty? Yes.
Did she touch it? Yes. And so she's
using her senses and she's saying
nothing is happening. It looks good. It
looks tasty. I hear that it can give me
wisdom. Satan is trying to lead her to
follow the testimony of her senses. It
says in Genesis 3:6, "So when the woman
saw that the tree was good for food, see
her eyes are involved." Her ears up to
this point have been involved as well.
That
was pleasant to the eyes, a tree
desirable to make one wise. She took of
its fruit and ate.
This reminds me of the story.
Did you catch it, folks?
Is that all Genesis 3:6 said? Here's
how far he read. So when the woman saw
that the tree was good for food and that
it was a delight to the eyes and that
the tree was to be desired to make one
wise, she took of its fruit and ate.
Is that where it ended?
Oh no. And she also gave some to her
husband who was with her and he ate.
Wow.
Sir, why did you partially quote Genesis
3:6,
the part that contradicts what Ellen
White says in the same book that you're
currently quoting from?
The part you conveniently skipped over
on both pages 53 and 55.
Why didn't you quote the whole verse,
sir? You're going to see, folks, he
doesn't go back to this. This is the end
of the use of the Bible, by the way, in
the presentation. He's just going to
move along.
Why did you withhold from the story hour
that Ellen White claims Adam wasn't
there with Eve? She wandered off on her
own. You got caught, sir.
You got caught.
You read through all the the pages 53 to
55 and most of 56 either by verbatim
quoting. He's actually not even done
yet,
at least with Ellen White's writings. He
is with the Bible. But you've been
quoting from all the way through from 53
to to 56 either by verbatim quoting or
paraphrasing. But you completely skipped
over this portion. Huh? I wonder why.
Remember folks, there's something
special about this chapter of Patriarchs
and Prophets. We were told that at the
very beginning when he quoted manuscript
releases volume 10,
it was given by God to keep people from
being deceived.
Really?
It's game over, folks. Game over.
Busted, sir.
You're not going to convince me that he
didn't purposefully leave that out and
not read all of verse six and also skip
over the portion of Ellen White's
writings that he's been quoting from and
that he doesn't catch this or it was an
honest mistake. No, you're not going to
convince me of that.
This man I've listened to, I don't know
how much of him. He has read thousands
of pages of Ellen White. I'm there with
him. I'm I understand how people like
that are. They know the narrative.
It's game over, folks.
As if it wasn't already with the other
contradictions. But there you go. You're
just going to quietly let that one
slide.
Adventist, give this stuff up. You're
being bamboozled, hoodwinkedked.
of Joseph and Samson.
You know when Piper's wife according to
p prophets and kings was prophets and
kings was very beautiful tried to entice
Joseph to commit adultery with her.
What did Joseph say? He said
how can I commit this act and sin
against God? What was the standard of
Joseph's decision? God's command. You
shall not commit adultery. But then on
the other hand, we have Samson
never saw a woman he didn't like.
So he sees this beautiful Philistine
woman says to his parents as was the
custom, you know, um, get her for me.
And do you know the reason he gives? Get
her for me because she has pleased my
eyes. And it cost him his eyes
because they were poked out. There's a
lesson there. Samson followed what his
eyes said, what his heart said, what his
emotions said. Joseph obeyed the
explicit word of God and ignored the
testimony of his senses when it
contradicted the word of God. Ellen
White wrote, "Eve really believed the
words of Satan, but her belief did not
save her from the penalty of sin. She
disbelieved the words of God. And this
was what led her to her fall. In the
judgment, men will not be condemned
because they conscientiously believed a
lie, but because they did not believe
the truth. Because they neglected the
opportunity of learning what is truth.
Notwithstanding the sopesty of Satan, to
the contrary, it is always disastrous to
disobey God. We must set our hearts to
know what is truth. All the lessons that
God has caused to be placed on record in
his word are for our warning and
instruction. They are given to save us
from deception. Their neglect will
resolve in ruin to ourselves. Whatever
contradicts God's word, we may be sure
proceeds from Satan.
Right after he omits the latter half of
Genesis 3:6 and skips over where
patriarchs and prophets contradicts it.
And watch when he gets to his fifth
point.
He's just going to pick up
where Ellen White's claiming she tempted
and enticed Adam and not even mention
the contradiction from the verse he
omitted. You're also going to notice a
hard stop on any sort of reference to
scripture.
Unbelievable, man. Give me a break.
given to protect from deception. No,
this is the deadly camouflage.
This is the deception by your own
standard.
Also, Stephen
Ellen White claimed to go against her
writings was to go against the spirit of
God
that you insult God when you do so. You
will end up in predition. It's the first
step in leading to you eventually
rejecting the Bible and then ending up
full-on in predition.
So don't give us this line about the
Bible being all one needs, only being
accountable to the Bible. Come on,
please.
Give me a break.
The volume at which you're quoting from
the bi the Bible versus Ellen White is
indicative of how much of her you've
read.
The tally thus far is 3 to one, folks.
We have 15 mentions of Ellen White
to five of scripture.
Two of those are the same verse
mentioned again.
Four verses.
Patriarchs and prophets, confrontation,
manuscript releases,
spiritual gifts.
Give me a break. This is cognitive
dissonance.
Oh, no. No. She said you only need the
Bible. Except for those times she said
that if you go against her writings,
you're going to end up in predition and
that you're insulting the spirit of God.
But aside from that, yeah, just the
Bible. But she also fills in the gaps on
the Bible. So, you're supposed to just
read the Bible, but there's a bunch of
gaps that you're not going to be able to
understand and and rightly arrive at the
right conclusion. So, you're going to
need the spirit of prophecy. See, it's
just the Bible, folks. That's all you
need. You just need the Bible.
Wake up, man.
Gal, whoever you may be, wake up. Wake
up.
So, the issue at the beginning is the
word of God and the word of Satan.
You see the issue at the beginning is
far more than a tree. By not eating from
the tree, Eve would be obeying God's
authority, the authority of his word. If
she ate from the tree, she would be
rejecting the authority of God who gave
the command. It is the same test that
will come at the end. Only the
difference is it won't be a tree.
It will be a day.
You see, the issue is not one day versus
another. The issue is if you keep the
Sabbath, you are obeying God's authority
who commanded to keep the Sabbath. If
you observe Sunday, you are obeying the
command of the power that claims to have
changed the day of worship. It is the
identical trial at the end of time. Only
the only difference is a day versus a
tree.
So, of course, in good old SDA fashion,
he has to try and find some way to make
this about the seventh day Sabbath.
Book, chapter, and verse. Stephen, where
does the Bible say anything remotely
close to what you just claimed?
Whole cloth, Ellen White mumbo jumbo.
Just like there was a tree in the
garden, there'll be a day in the end.
Nothing in scripture,
nothing says the end of the world,
salvation, etc., is going to come down
to a day. Notice the assumptions. So,
this is a perfect example for us to to
examine some presuppositions here. He
said the issue isn't one day versus
another. The issue is if you keep the
Sabbath, you're obeying God's authority
who commanded to keep the Sabbath. And
this is precisely the issue. It's just
assumed that the SDA church's novel
doctrine that they call Sabbathkeeping
is how one keeps the Sabbath.
It's just assumed that that means going
to church on Saturday in an Adventist
church. Yes, it has to be an Adventist
church. He's leaving that part out.
If you remember a few months ago, we
looked at uh Dr. O, who claimed
Sabbathkeeping, aka going to church on
Saturday, is not enough. You have to
have the spirit of prophecy, Ellen
White, and the three angels messages.
Adventists, you don't have a monopoly on
the Sabbath. You did not revive
something that was lost due to the
papacy or Constantine or the Council of
Leadyia, all the other excuses that the
SDA church has passed along to people.
You guys have a tradition that you
inherited from the 19th century that you
call Sabbathkeeping.
And this is one of the most doctrinally
divided aspects of Adventist theology.
In the general, they'll all say that
going to church is keeping the Sabbath,
but press them on on the dos and and
don't, the actual dos and don'ts, and
watch a 100 different SDAs give you 100
different answers. It's all arbitrary.
This is precisely why their old creation
memorial observance is weak.
They want to appeal to creation for its
binding validity, but then they have to
appeal to Moses to show you how to the
potential dos and don'ts of how the
Sabbath is kept, even though they
arbitrarily pick and choose from there
as well. It isn't about rest. It's about
their tradition and being part of a
small little group that has the the
truth.
That's what it's really about. And
that's what Stephen is getting at. The
new creation memorial position of the
first day, which the again the Christian
church has understood for quite
literally almost 2,000 years, does not
have this problem because we understand
the day is not the substance. The day is
the memorial. The substance is Jesus.
The memorial can change while the
substance remains the same.
The form looks different now than it did
then. The substance is still the same.
This is why the author goes to great
lengths to try and explain to you in
Hebrews 3 and4 why Israel who was
keeping the Sabbath the way the
Adventists think Sabbath is kept failed
to enter in.
Adventists will say oh no it's because
they didn't believe right they didn't
believe and it's belief that enters in.
It's not the
the substance is the same, folks. The
memorial the day is not the substance.
It points to the substance.
But the the new creation memorial
position, which is the historic
Christian position, doesn't have this
inconsistent problem that the SDAs have
where they're constantly pointing back
to what's old and gone, the fallen
creation. They want to go back to the
old fallen creation, the old covenant.
They want to go back. Everything's
always back, back, back. It's like, "No,
dude. We're going forward."
What?
They're all facing back. Christians are
like, "Nah, dude. We're like,
it's just crazy, man." Makes this thing
about, of course, the seventh day
Sabbath.
They're the ones who supposedly observe
God's authority. No one else does
because they don't go to church on
Saturday and claim to have Ellen White
and the three angels messages. But
they'll bear false witness about
Christians, violating the ninth
commandment and say they have no
biblical basis for why we practice what
we do. No, the actual answer and the
honest answer instead of bearing false
witness and lying would be, "Well, they
do have verses that they used, but we
disagree with their interpretation and
hermeneutics."
Yet they'll cut things whole cloth out
of the out of Ellen White that are
nowhere even close to found in the Bible
and say we're following tradition and
reading things into the Bible that
aren't there. When in reality it's like
no, we're actually doing biblical
theology. We're trying to look at the
whole of the matter from start to
finish. Not just staying stuck in the
old creation that fell that Jesus came
to redeem. And we're living in the the
substance now, going somewhere, waiting
for the consummation of the ages where
the curse is lifted off of this present
creation that Jesus redeemed as well,
which we're a part of.
Longing for the day that we have our
glorified bodies, remembering that and
celebrating that the day that Jesus
accomplished that that work of
redemption, which was the first day when
he walked out of the tomb. Give me a
break that there's no biblical support
for this. You disagree. That's what it
is. You disagree. So in your mind,
because it's not what you believe,
it's not biblical.
Give me a break. Serpents had were gold
and had wings. Yeah. Okay. Do biblical
theology for me on that one, Adventist.
And let's look at the whole of scripture
and you show me where that's at because
we can do biblical theology and give
support for the first day. We're not the
ones stuck in the verbatim fallacy where
it has to be verbatim in there where you
only use that standard when you need it
as a cudgel.
It's all a grand conspiracy. The Sabbath
is just all this grand conspiracy.
Everyone hates the Sabbath supposedly.
They're a one commandment church. That's
what they are. They're a one commandment
keeping and and even that commandment
they don't understand correctly.
Zero commandment keeping church.
Speaking of bearing false witness,
he mentions the classic the papacy
changed the Sabbath myth that we've
debunked I don't know how many times and
we will continue to say this Stephen
because you guys don't know actual
church history only what Ellen White
claims in the great controversy. You
don't understand what Rome is saying or
why the Christian church worships on the
first day. So let's break this down
again folks for those that do not know.
the papacy, Constantine, Council of
Leadyia, whatever boogeyman you want to
insert.
Council of Leadyia, for example, folks,
it it just shows you don't even know
what you're quoting. That wasn't an
ecumenical council. It wasn't even it
was a regional council. And it didn't
even change anything. It's like, dude,
go and look at canon 6. I think it's
canon 6 or canon 9 of council leadsa. It
mand. It's just like, oh my goodness,
man. It is just crazy. It's like you
don't know what you're quoting from.
that had no binding authority in the
entirety of the west, let alone the
east. There was no eastern
representation at the council of
Leodysia. Yet the eastern church was
also worshiping on the first day. How
does a regional council that's not even
ecumenical, that has zero representation
from the east?
How is that where it was like decided
the Sabbath was? It's just horrible
argumentation, folks.
They those things never change the
Sabbath. Adventists love to point to
these obscure articles from Roman
Catholics that say Protestants have no
basis to worship on the first day
because the Roman Catholic Church made
this change. What do they mean? What
does Rome mean when they say this? Well,
if you go and actually do the study of
the context of these statements, you're
going to find that what's being said in
the larger it's being said in a larger
context of apostolic succession and
church authority.
The Roman church believes that the
apostles were the first Roman Catholics.
That is central to Roman Catholicism.
Protestants argued, well, we go back to
the the the
apostles in theologically. We're arguing
that we're attached theologically. It's
not necessarily through a magisterial
hierarchy like Rome would claim to some
degree.
But when Rome
says
the Roman Catholic Church changed the
Sabbath, that is synonymous with them
saying the apostles instituted worship
on Sundays. Those two statements are
synonymous in Rome's eyes. They're
saying the apostles did this. That's
what they're saying when they say that.
So, because that's what they believe and
they believe Protestants have no
connection back to the apostles,
they say we have no basis for worshiping
on Sunday. and not observing the Jewish
Sabbath.
It is the apostles that are in focus in
this discussion. We don't agree with
them obviously and that we have zero
connection back to the apostles.
Different discussion for a different
day. But the point is is that's the
context that it's being said in. But
because SDAs have sadly been brainwashed
without being shown the the full picture
of what's going on here, they see these
single statements and then run with
them, inserting all these spurious
conspiratorial ideas from Ellen White
into the quotes. That isn't at all what
Rome is saying.
Is Ellen White and the SDA pioneers
being confused and quote mining Roman
Catholic statements to support their
narrative.
The Adventist Church reads into these
statements that Rome is admitting that
the papacy rose up hundreds of years
after the apostles usurped authority
that only God has and changed the law of
God.
That is not what they're saying at all.
This is typically where they also lie
and bear false witness and say Rome
removed some of the ten commandments.
Yet no, they're all there in the dua
trans translation which is the Roman
Catholic translation. They didn't remove
any commandments. They conjoined uh the
first and second commandments in their
catechism
because a catechism is a teaching tool.
It isn't a Bible.
They did it for teaching purposes.
Because the first and second
commandments have to do with idolatry.
They're trying to show the breakdown of
the law. This idea that everyone hates
the ten commandments except Adventists.
Give me a break. The Christian church
has rightly understood the use of the
Ten Commandments for 2,000 years. It's
only been when Judaizing heretic groups
spring up like the Adventists who claim
everyone else is confused, everyone else
is lost, everyone give me a break.
SDAs will nefariously assert that Rome
removed the second commandment to permit
idolatry. No, they didn't. It's in their
translation.
Go look it up. It takes like 10 seconds
to refute this. It's in the DA res
translation. It's still in the
catechism. It just doesn't have a two
next to the to to it. The words are
still there. The commandment is still
there.
When it comes to the supposed changing
of the Sabbath, you guys don't even cite
official source materials. Most of the
time, like the old Catholic Mirror
article they've circulated for decades,
they think it's like a trump card. They
share this thing on Facebook all the
time. And it's just like, oh my
goodness, man. It would be like me
citing Steven Boore and then equating
that with being officially published
sources from the SDA organization.
It's like an obscure newspaper article
from
some Joemo
and that's supposed to be the proof that
see the the Roman Catholic Church.
Every time SDAs assert this, they are
violating the Ninth Commandment,
bearing false witness about both
Protestants and Catholics.
And if you keep doing it now after
hearing it, you're 100% bearing false
witness.
Stop saying this. It's a lie.
But they have to because Ellen White
said it.
I understand some SDAs, they are just
regurgitating what they've been told,
but they've been sold the bill of goods.
It is not what Rome is saying when they
say that. It does not support the SDA
narrative. This is no different when
they try and latch on to the 1880s and
say there were Sunday laws even though
it looked literally nothing like what
the SDA church claims. There was no
persecution. There was no forced
worship. And we're going to be
responding to that. That's actually the
video of Steven Bore I wanted to review
first and respond to on here, but um
we're breaking the ice here with this.
But we will be covering that at some
point because he goes on about this and
cites all sorts of people and we're
going to bring these people up,
Puritans, people that are my spiritual
ancestors, and they try and pigeon hole
them into this idea that they laid the
framework and foundation for Sunday
laws. And it looked nothing like the SDA
church claimed. There was no
persecution. There was no forced
worship. They claim there was
persecution, but then they won't tell
you the aspects where um at the time
we're talking about the the the
governmental breakdown in some areas not
being like jurisdictions not being the
same.
We'll get into all that because even
during that he doesn't even quote
necessarily only from like I said the
1800s. He quotes from like Puritans and
different different video for a
different time. Let's get back into
this.
Let's go to the fifth method.
Once Satan gains the victory over
people, he uses those people to tempt
other people.
Notice what Ellen White wrote in
Patriots and Prophets page 56 and 57
regarding Adam. Let's talk now about
Adam.
Love, gratitude,
loyalty to the creator. All were
overborn
by love to Eve. She was a part of
himself and he could not endure the
thought of separation. He did not
realize that the same infinite power who
had from the dust of the earth created
him a living beautiful form and had in
love given him com companion could
supply her place. He resolved to share
her fate. If she must die, he would die
with her. And now notice how your
reasoning powers when they're not under
the control of the Holy Spirit can lead
you astray. She continued, "After all,
he reasoned.
Might not the words of the wise serpent
be true."
By the way,
they did not become naked until after
Adam sinned.
I won't get into the theology of that,
but that's significant
really.
They weren't naked till after Adam
sinned. Is that what the text says?
There's a reason for this like he
mentioned.
There's theological implications, but
Ellen White said, so they have to find a
way to to make it work.
This is more Ellen White being read into
the scriptures. Folks, let's examine.
Okay, let's first read Genesis 2:21-2.
So the Lord God caused a deep sleep to
fall upon the man. This is prior to the
the fall. Genesis 2.
And while he slept, took one of his ribs
and closed up its place with flesh. And
the rib that the Lord God had taken from
the man, he made into a woman and
brought her to the man. Then the man
said, this is also again folks after the
command from God has been given to the
man Adam.
She hadn't even been created yet.
Then the man said, "This is at last.
This at last is bone of my bones and
flesh of my flesh. She shall be called
woman because she was taken out of man.
Therefore, a man shall leave his father
and his mother, and hold fast to his
wife, and they uh and they shall become
one flesh. And the man and his wife were
both naked, and were not ashamed.
No, Adam and Eve didn't become naked
after Adam sinn. They were created as
such, but weren't ashamed of it.
and the man and his wife were both naked
and were not ashamed. So what happened
after the fall?
Had Steven bothered to read more than
five verses.
Simply two verses passed where he ended
up with the chopping off of the tail end
of verse 6, he would have seen where
Ellen White yet again contradicts the
story. Genesis 3 6-11.
What does it say?
So when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food, that it was a delight to
the eyes, and that the tree was to be
desired to make one wise, she took of
its fruit and ate.
And she also gave some to her husband,
who was with her, and he ate. Then the
eyes of both were opened, and they knew
that they were naked. And they sewed
figs together, and made themselves loin
claws. And they heard the sound of the
Lord God walking in the garden in the
cool of the day. And the man and his
wife hid themselves from the presence of
the Lord God among the trees of the
garden. But the Lord God called to the
man and said to him, "Where are you?"
And he said, "I heard the sound of you
in the garden, and I was afraid because
I was naked, and I have hid myself." He
said, "Who told you that you were naked?
Have you eaten of the tree of which I
commanded you not to eat?
Adam and Eve were created naked with no
shame. After the fall, in awareness of
this nakedness brought with it shame.
They did not become naked.
But Steven Bore teaches what Ellen White
taught that when they fell, they became
naked by losing a white robe of light
that enshrouded them. Something that, as
you've probably figured by now, is
nowhere to be found in the biblical
text.
He's going to mention this
which is why it's as he said so very
important to their system.
That's strike uh three just in in this
presentation. Three contradictions.
Eve was before him as beautiful and
apparently as innocent as before this
act of disobedience. If she had lost her
life, that would not be true.
She expressed greater love for him than
before. Oh, Adam, I love you more than
ever. No sign of death appeared in her,
and he decided to brave the
consequences. He seized the fruit and
quickly ate.
Do you know what Adam's sin was? He
loved the gift more than the giver. He
loved Eve more than he loved God.
Satan's fifth method.
So there you heard it. He said, "Eve
didn't lose her robe of light when she
sinned, which is why Adam was able to be
deceived because she appeared to be
unharmed when he saw her."
He wasn't with her, but he didn't
mention that part. He didn't read from
from that part of Patriarchs and
Prophets, but it's just kind of implied
there.
But because she she
didn't lose her robe of light when she
sinned. That's why Adam was able to be
deceived because she appeared to be
unharmed when he saw her. Adam wasn't
deceived as we saw earlier 1 Timothy 2.
That is not why he sinned. Just more
Bible blunders on Ellen White's part.
Notice too folks in Genesis 3:14-19
where God is laying out the punishments
for Adam, Eve and the serpent, there is
a difference between what he tells Eve
and what he tells Adam. Eve is simply
told that there will be pain in
childbearing and her husband will rule
over her and it will be her natural
desire now to usurp that role. But what
does he say to Adam? Genesis 3:17, what
does he tell Adam? Because you've
listened to the voice of your wife and
you've eaten of the tree of which I
commanded you,
you shall not eat of it, cursed is the
ground because of you."
He didn't tell that to Eve because God
didn't command it to her. He commanded
it to Adam before Eve was even formed.
And it would have been his duty as her
husband to teach her the word of God.
You seeing the perversion of the story
here?
He said Adam's sin was that he loved the
gift more than the giver. Again, the
text does not say this. And I'm going to
keep mentioning that because this is the
same movement that wants to use the
verbatim fallacy when it's convenient.
As you've seen this whole night, when it
supports their system, they're
completely fine with inference.
Deduction
doesn't have to be stated verbatim. But
it's only okay when Adventists do it.
the never- ending contradiction.
Adam blamed Eve when God questioned him.
Genesis 3:12.
So was the woman that he gave me. She
gave me the fruit and I ate.
I I get what he's saying in the in the
sense of like inference and and whatnot
that he did it for his wife. And but
again, the text does not verbatim say
that. So don't use the verbatim fallacy,
Adventists, unless you're going to
consistently hold that standard.
is to lead people
to lead other people astray.
Let me just read this statement. Great
controversy, page 595.
Satan is constantly endeavoring to
attract attention to man in the place of
God.
He leads the people to look to bishops,
to pastors, to professors of theology as
their guides
instead of searching the scriptures to
learn their duty for themselves.
Then by controlling the minds of these
leaders, in other words, of bishops,
pastors, professors of theology, none of
the pastors in the Michigan conference.
By controlling them, he can influence
the multitudes according to his will.
We cannot trust the word of anyone that
is not in harmony with what God says in
his word. It's simple. You know, Eve
should have said, you know,
what you say seems reasonable. The fruit
looks good
and your your logic appears to be
correct. I didn't know that servants
could speak. I know that you know some
things about God's word. There's only
one problem. God said, "Don't eat." And
we live by every word that proceeds out
of the mouth of God. Period. Our only
protection
is in studying and obeying the word of
God.
Our only protection
is in studying and obeying the word of
God. Sir, you've quoted Ellen White 17
times so far in contrast to the Bible
five times. Two of which were the same
verse. The same woman that said if you
go against her writings, you're going
against the spirit of God and insult the
spirit of God.
Stephen, you yourself just got done
saying
you're so grateful for her writings
because they fill in the gaps. But now
you're telling us our only protection is
in studying the word of God.
How can one do that if they can't fill
in the gaps without Ellen White?
You cited Ellen at the beginning in the
in manuscript releases volume 10 saying
the chapter of patriarchs and prophets
is to protect one from deception on top
of talking about cognitive dissonance.
Sir, I think you might have cognitive
dissonance.
Either that or the same sort of
short-term memory that you claimed Eve
apparently had.
The irony,
this is where the downplaying of learned
men comes into play as well in
Adventism. For those that don't know,
the pioneers had this sort of like anti-
theological training attitude.
This has permeated SDAs to this day who
oftentimes bawk and scoff at qualified
educated teachers. That is, unless
you're an Adventist, of course, like the
pastors of the Michigan conference, like
he said, then it's totally normal and
fine. But not those heathen Sunday
theologians. Their minds are controlled
by Satan to deceive people. Satan's
using the non-SDA theologians to further
his agenda and deceive the mass of
Christians. Slander, lies, and bearing
false witness. It is the Ellen White
way.
It's cult-like behavior, too. Don't
listen to anyone who disagrees with us.
Only listen to the echo chamber. They're
all mouthpieces of the devil like Eve
was with Adam.
But then he puts the cherry on top.
He said, "We can't trust the word of of
anyone who's not in harmony with the
word of God."
So, thank you, sir. Ellen White cannot
be trusted, as we've demonstrated over
and over and over again on this channel,
but even in the stream, the irony, the
lack of self-awareness.
You deceptively skipped over the end of
Genesis 3:6, which contradicts the
primary source you've been quoting from
the whole night. By your own standard,
which is coming from Ellen White, we
can't trust anything that you said
tonight. You must be a mouthpiece for
Satan like Eve was with Adam. Thank you
for the tacid admission, sir. Simple,
right?
Unbelievable.
The the lack of self-awareness.
It just it goes to show how either how
strong it can be. I don't want to read
into Stephen's motives and say that he's
like a malicious person, an evil person.
I do think he knowingly skipped over and
didn't read the rest of Genesis. There's
no possible way to to miss that. There's
no possible way.
You know, spiritualism is going to be a
method that Satan is going to use to
deceive at the end of time. Ellen White
wrote in great controversy page 552
Satan has power to bring before men the
appearance of their departed friends
the counterfeit is perfect. What is a
perfect counterfeit?
It's when even the government cannot
detect a counterfeit $100 bill.
Ah, so spiritualism,
this is code speak for those that don't
know, uh, inside baseball.
Um, referring to those that believe uh,
spirits are conscious entities and that
spirits of humans don't die when their
body does. They'll lump all all they'll
lump the pagan Sunday Christians in with
the new age and just any any group of
people that believe differently than
they do about you having a conscious
immaterial spirit. Like most things,
they then caricature this to mean that
everyone who thinks this believes we can
communicate with the dead.
More ignorance on Ellen White's part.
Ironically,
every time I hear them say this, it's
like Mrs. White did such a did this
exact thing after her husband James
died.
Oh, it was only a vision. It's their
excuse to Oh, it was only a vision.
We're not saying it's not the same thing
as
whenever I hear SDAs bring this up, I
almost strain an optic nerve rolling my
eyes so hard.
It is a neverending merrygoround of
contradictions, inconsistency, and
hypocrisy. Not just that, but she
claimed to be given a green cord from
her accompanying angel that she was told
to hold tightly to her bosom and Jesus
would appear.
a green green cord occult imagery like
known oult imagery
yet she's the person we're supposed to
be heeding spiritual warning from right
okay got it
you want to check that quote I believe
it's I know it's early writings I
believe it's page 57 if you have the LG
white app you can liter or the
egwritings you can just put in uh green
cord probably and search and just look
for the on the sidebar the source that's
ew pretty sure it's Page 57. It's at the
very end, the final paragraph of
whatever page it's on. Green cord occult
magic. Hold it to your bosom
and Jesus will appear for you. Oh, but
it's it's all just visions though. That
makes it better, right? We're not saying
he physically manifested therefore,
right? You're just claiming that she was
shown this in vision. She was
Okay, getting to the tail end here.
Here, folks.
The counterfeit is perfect. The familiar
look, the words, the tone are reproduced
with marvelous distinctness.
Many are comforted with the assurance
that their loved ones are enjoy.
Look real quick. Look how many people
are totally zonked out. Completely
asleep.
You got I don't know if that lady is is
asleep. This dude is like zonked. This
guy's out.
This lady's totally zonked.
I mean, not a single one of these
individuals
look like they are happy to be there. It
looks like a spiritual desert.
And is it really shocking?
There's no gospel in this presentation.
There's no actual good news proclaimed.
just ramblings of a last generation
theologian who read Ellen White to them
for an hour, sprinkling in a few Bible
passages.
A qualified pastor brings every message,
yes, every message back to the gospel.
The gospel is not just for the lost,
folks. Believers need washed in it
daily.
But this is the problem. In Steven's
eyes, this is the gospel.
The Adventist system and package of
theology is the gospel for Adventists.
It's the Adventist message that
supposedly is the power of God unto
salvation. Romans 1:16-1 17.
It's the Adventist message that Paul
wasn't ashamed of. Not eating pork or
shrimp. That's part of the power of God
unto salvation. Apparently,
the gospel is not every single doctrine
and belief that one holds to. It is a
specific message that was revealed by
Jesus Christ to the apostles, handed
down to the saints. He didn't reveal to
them the health message, the
investigative judgment, that Ellen White
would come along and be an inspired
prophetist, young earth creationism.
None of that is the gospel. Those are
theological topics and categories, but
that's not the power of God to
salvation.
The gospel is the good news about how
rebel sinners can be united with their
creator through the person and work of
Jesus Christ, the God man.
It is a triune act by the triune God,
the father giving his son, the father
and son sending the spirit to seal those
people. The gospel, we're not going to
get into all this tonight, but the
gospel is a trinitarian message. The
apostles were experientially
trinitarians.
They had Jesus in their midst, the
incarnation of the son, being told about
the father, hearing the father speak
from heaven upon the son, then being
promised to be given the holy spirit,
and then the holy spirit is poured out
on them at Pentecost.
They were experiential trinitarians, and
then the church continued building upon
this.
That's the gospel that Christ is ruling
and reigning, making all of his enemies
a foottool. the gospel of the kingdom
that Jesus went about preaching. Matthew
4:23, the gospel of the kingdom,
not that it's some faroff thing, some
faroff place at some point later on for
who even knows what. No, he came for the
here and the now to redeem this. Jesus
said in Mark 4, I believe it's Mark 4,
if I cast out demons, the spirit or the
kingdom of God has come upon you. Was
Jesus casting out demons?
Repent for the kingdom of heaven is at
hand. It's not at hand 2,000 years
later. He's ruling and reigning now.
He's making all things new. Revelation
215. He redeemed even the fallen
creation which we're a part of. And one
day we're going to live eternally with
our maker face to face again. That is
the gospel. Then you get into the
mechanics of okay well how does a person
experience that? You have to be a
vegetarian to do that. You have to
affirm the investigative judgment. You
have to affirm young earth creationism.
No,
that's not the gospel, folks.
Enjoy the bliss of heaven and without
suspicion of danger, they give ear to
seducing spirits and doctrines of
devils.
Have you ever heard of the acid test? We
need to put things through the acid
test. Let me explain what the acid test
is.
The acid test is when you want to
determine whether a metal is gold or
not. When you put a drop of a strong
acid on any metal other than gold, it
fizzles.
But when you put the acid on the gold,
it doesn't fizzle. So you have an
external test that shows to you whether
a metal is gold or not. The test is
decisive, immediate, cheap, simple, and
trustworthy.
You can't depend on it looking like
gold, biting it, you know something,
biting it to see if it's gold or it
feels like gold. No, if you go by those
standards, you must might just have
fool's gold.
I want to end by reading a couple
statements from the spirit of prophecy.
Great controversy 593.
The last great delusion
is soon to open before us. Antichrist is
to perform his marvelous works in our
sight.
So closely will the counterfeit resemble
the truth that it will be impossible to
distinguish between them except by the
holy scriptures. By their testimony,
every statement and every miracle must
be tested.
We used to be a people of the book. Now
we are a people of the iPhone.
We are the people of the internet. And
we waste hours and hours and hours
texting.
Many times nonsense. I'm not saying that
this technology is bad, but we waste
hours and hours and hours. People ask
me, they say, "What do you do when you
take a long flight?" I have my computer.
I'm writing sermons. I'm writing
studies.
That's what we need to do, folks. We
need to get back to the Bible. We need
to study the Bible. We need to practice
the Bible. We need to plead for the
power of the Holy Spirit to plant the
word in our hearts that we might not sin
against the Lord. Ellen White wrote in
great controversy page 624
626 that Satan is going to personate the
second coming of Christ and everyone
except the elect is going to believe
that he is Christ. In this context,
Ellen White wrote, "Only those who have
been diligent students of the
scriptures, not only diligent students
of the scriptures and who have received
the love of the truth, will be shielded
from the powerful delusion that takes
the world captive by the Bible
testimony. These will detect the
deceiver in his disguise. To all the
testing time will come. By the sifting
of temptation, the genuine Christian
will be revealed." Are the people of God
now so firmly established upon his word
that they would not yield to the
evidence of their senses?
Would they in such a crisis cling to the
Bible and the Bible only? Satan will, if
possible, prevent them from obtaining a
preparation to stand in that day. He
will so arrange affairs as to hedge up
their way and tangle them with earthly
treasures. Cause them to carry a heavy
wearisome burden that their hearts may
be overcharged with the cares of his
life and the day of trial may come upon
them as a thief.
Man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of God.
The acid test.
Fool's gold.
Stephen, imagine if you applied the acid
test to Ellen White.
The test is decisive, immediate, cheap,
and trustworthy.
You can't depend on the appearance
because Ellen White is fool's gold.
She doesn't even come close to passing
the test.
Shoot. You sprinkled the stuff on there
and it's not just bubbling. It's like
popping. It's like crackling. It's like
fireworks going off.
Ellen White was quoted and referenced
openly 20 times, folks.
Not even including all the paraphrasing
he did where he didn't mention that's
what he was doing. 20 times. The Bible.
Five.
five times.
Don't tell me the Adventist church only
believes the Bible.
The Adventists who don't like
traditional Adventism are obviously
going to scoff at this and say that
their pastor is not like bore or
whatever. Doesn't change the facts. This
is one of countless examples.
And the fact that you have people that
are bing and scoffing at that shows you
guys fit your own bill for Babylon.
Seventh Adventist theology is built upon
Ellen White. The Adventist Church is
built upon Ellen White. The great
controversy worldview is from Ellen
White.
Supposedly given in a vision at a
funeral. The Bible is simply used as a
prop and a conduit to sprinkle in
periodically to make it look like what
Ellen White is saying is in line with
the Bible.
Even though, as we saw and heard, she
supposedly fills in the gaps. meaning
the scriptures are not sufficient.
Gaps would mean that something needs
filled in.
And again talks about formally being a
people of the book and cites Ellen White
saying such. Yet this same woman,
the same woman said her writings were
authored by the Holy Spirit. Going
against them will lead to predition. You
insult the spirit of God by doing so.
You only need the Bible. Remember,
the Adventist Church views Ellen White's
writings as the words of God, just like
Ellen claimed about them. Cognitive
dissonance, folks. Cognitive dissonance.
Again, you if you're an Adventist, you
can keep telling us all day long,
come on here, contact me. We got a guy
coming on uh not next week, but the week
after, the first Adventist, who we'll
see if he actually, you know, shows up.
He's going to have 10 to 15 minutes up
to uninterrupted to give his best pitch
for a specific doctrine.
Then we're going to examine it afterward
from the Bible.
If you want to convince us, no, no, no.
We can defend everything we believe from
the Bible.
Okay. Shoot me an email. Come on.
Answering Adventism and let's see.
Let's see you come on here and defend
only from the Bible. And let's let's see
your exegetical breakdown of Protestants
going to hunt down 7th Day Adventists
for going to church on Saturday.
Defending that is not simply proof
texting like it's a trump card.
No. that I was just in John Frame
systematic theology the other day and he
so perfectly put it in there. He said
that proof texting is often criticized
and rightfully so because oftent times
verses are just being cited. The purpose
of proof texting is to give a person an
idea of where you're quoting from, but
you should understand the context of
where you're pulling it from because you
should be able to speak about the
surrounding context, etc. That's the
evidence of a person of of knowing if a
person knows where they're quoting from
or not. Are they just simply citing the
text or are they giving you the place
that they're quoting from to give you
the idea, but they understand the flow
and stuff of what's there? So, if you're
an Adventist and you want to come do
that, email me answering
adventism@gmail.com.
You can come on here 10 to 15 minutes or
so up to give your best pitch. I have a
whole list, a whole host of topics.
We're not doing these general vague, oh
well, uh, continuationism that the
spiritual g the the prophetic, you know,
gift is still is still active. Well, no,
you want to defend that to defend Ellen
White. So, let's just do your unique
thing. Okay, come on here. Let's see if
Ellen White passes the biblical test of
a prophet. I've got the the fundamental
beliefs book of the SDA church right
there. We'll use the standard that's in
that book. Okay?
It's going to be specifics. It's going
to be SDA specific doctrines, not these
general vague to try and obuscate.
That's what it is. We're going to get
specific. Was Jesus exalted to be made
equal with the father? That's part of
the great controversy narrative. It's
necessary.
Let's see that from scripture.
Two shows next week, folks. Two shows.
One's going to be out on the road, so
that'll be interesting to see. Monday
show with Dr. Alan Davis. He'll be back.
We're going to be talking about last
generation theology actually. So that
will be on Monday. Um like I said, I'll
be doing some traveling. And so uh for
those that don't know, Dr. Davis was
platformed by some SDA organizations,
Amazing Facts, Weimar Institute, um
specifically to teach last generation
theology. Um so those organizations are
obviously not the SDA or organization
itself, but they're rather prominent
Adventist institutions. And so, um,
yeah, should be a pretty good show.
Thursday, uh, the boys are going to be
back. Uh, EJ Thunder Lorston and CMB the
Ambassador. Going to be going over and
discussing Ellen White's racism.
Um, I knew when I posted my video from a
couple weeks ago, they would all
manifest and they would uh make the
classic arguments that FD Nickel did and
the stuff they've inherited from the 60s
and 50s. But we're going to be
responding to all that um and showing
that the Adventist defense to these
things is just them paring the talking
points like I said of their scholars and
their pivot and change on those things.
So we're going to go through all the
receipts, the actual source
documentation and show that no, the
critics are not just taking her out of
context. Um the narrative on this has
changed and then actually there'll be
three shows kind of next week. There'll
be one on Friday. Um, we're going to be
doing a big announcement stream. I've
been talking about this a little bit.
Um, some things came up and kind of
pushed it out a little bit. It was
supposed to be tomorrow. Um, going to
get pushed out a week and that will be
fine. But we're going to be talking
about some exciting things on the
horizon. Um, as well as our need for you
all to be a part of that and some cool
um, things that are kind of in the
pipeline on that front. So, there you go
folks. Um,
there you go. That's uh lot there
contradicts scripture. Whatever
contradicts God's word, we can be sure
proceeds from Satan.
You saw the SDA guy
despite what the text said, he said,
well, there would have had to have been
a convers. That's how it works, folks.
They have to defend it. These same
types, I don't know about that guy, but
these same types will tell you, "No, no,
no. I don't even read Ellen White." And
then you'll point out one of these
contradictions. Now they're defending
it. All of a sudden, they pivot and now
they have to defend it.
So, be praying for Adventists, folks.
It's It's very, you know, it's it's
being this removed from it at this
point. It's kind of easy sometimes to
forget
being in that state and how difficult it
is. It is a lot, especially too if all
of your family is there. It's your
comfort zone. Um,
so I get it. I get it. But folks, the
call is to follow the truth wherever it
leads. Wherever he leads,
it is not Adventism.
All the stuff that makes Adventism
unique, their supposed, you know, claim
to contribution to the the the world,
all false.
There's nothing unique to Adventism that
needs to be salvaged. I have an
interview that's I did some months ago
with some Adventist pastors. Looks like
it's going to be releasing here in the
next month or so. Um, and so it'll be
streaming on this channel as well. And
they they tried to they tried to pull
that card like, "Well, don't you think
there's a lot of good there to salvage?"
No.
Nope.
When you have a false god, a false
gospel, a false church, and a false
prophet.
Nope. Nope.
Christianity was around long before the
1800s. And don't try and use this. Oh,
the reformers did the same. No.
Reformation and restoration are not the
same thing. So, anyways, as always,
folks, the call to Adventists to come
out of her, my people. It's time. It's
time, folks.
As always, until next time. God bless.
[Music]